IT REALLY IS THAT A GOOD PLACE
TO BE OBVIOUSLY THIS AFTERNOON
I'M PLEASED THAT I'VE BEEN
JOINED BY TWO OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE UP WAS TO TING IS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM OF THE BAY
AREA SAN FRANCISCO BUT HE'S
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE BUDGET.
AND WE HAVE ALSO WITH THIS.
REMEMBER A REGINALD BYRON JONES
SAWYER. WHO IS A JUNIOR. WHO IS
OF FROM THE BAIT LOS ANGELES
AREA HE IS CHAIR OF PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND I'M HAPPY TO HAVE
THEM WITH US TODAY ALSO IN THE
AUDIENCE IS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TODD GLORIA I THINK HE'S HAS
COME YET HE'S COMING IN. HE
VISITED THAT DONOVAN LAST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO SO HE WANTED
TO ALSO BE A PART IN HERE. THE
INFORMATION AND PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROCESS. ONE THANK ALL OF
OUR STAFF TO HELP TO UP.
OBVIOUSLY TO PUT THIS TOGETHER
FOR US HERE IN SAN DIEGO. I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER
AND I REPRESENT THE SEVENTY
NINTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT BUT I'M
ALSO. OKAY THANK YOU. I'M ALSO
THE CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY OUT
AND- SHOW THE PUBLIC SAFETY
BUDGET. AND SO PART OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
IS CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST STATE
DEPARTMENT. WITH FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND BUDGET POSITIONS.
THIRTY FIVE STATE OWNED AND
OPERATED PRISONS A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND A CART
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. A
PAROLE POPULATION OF MORE THAN
FIFTY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE AND A
BUDGET OF MORE THAN THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. WE
ARE WAITING FOR THE LATEST
RECIDIVISM REPORT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN COHORT TO
RELEASE IT OF RELEASE
INDIVIDUALS BUT HISTORICALLY WE
PUBLIC AROUND 6265% RECIDIVISM
RANGE. EARLIER THIS YEAR THIS
SUB COMMITTEE JUST DISCUSS THE
AUDIT OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROGRAM WHICH WE HOPE TO GET A
PROGRESS UPDATE PROGRAM A
PROGRESS REPORT UPDATE TODAY.
WE'VE GOT WE'VE DISCUSSED A
BROKEN STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED IN HIS ADDRESSING
AND WE DISCUSS THE MANY BUDGET
PROPOSALS THAT COME TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE INCLUDING CAPITAL
OUTLAY AND NEW PROGRAMS. THIS
INFORMATION HEARING SEEKS TO
CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION OF THE DIRECTION OF
THE LARGEST PRISON SYSTEM IN
THE COUNTRY. WE'VE MADE
PROGRESS BUT WE ARE FAR FROM
WHERE WE NEED TO BE. WE'VE COME
UP WITH CONVENE CDC ARE AS WELL
AS STAKEHOLDERS IN THE LA L. TO
PROVIDE US WITH THEIR VISION.
AND INFORMATION IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT SO
THAT WE ARE MEETING OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY GOALS. WE'RE IMPROVING
THE OUTCOMES OF PEOPLE IN
CUSTODY AND WE RESPONSIBLY
PRIORITIZING RESOURCES. SOMEONE
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR COMING
TODAY BEING A PART OF THIS
HEARING. OF THIS HEARING TODAY
HAD THE PANELS OF SOME OF YOU
RECEIVE THE AGENDA OUTSIDE. WE
HAVE THREE OF THREE PANELS ONE
ON THE FUTURE OF CORRECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE SECOND PANEL
STRATEGIES THE POPULATION
MANAGEMENT AND THE THIRD PANEL
IS SUCCESSFUL RE ENTRY. GOING
TO TRY TO BE AS EFFICIENT AS
POSSIBLE AND BASICALLY
ADDRESSING THESE THREE SO THAT
WE WILL HAVE TIME AT THE END
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. SO IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS WILL HAVE TAKE
ALL THOSE UP IN A WILL HERE FOR
ME TO PANEL WE'LL SEE IF THERE
MEMBERS IF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I WANT TO
ASK. BUT WITH TIME IS VERY IN
FOR A PUBLIC. HOPE SAVE ABOUT
THIRTY MINUTES THAT AT THE END
OF THE ALL OF ME I'M OUT OF
INTEREST AND ONE IS WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND HOPEFULLY. OPENING UP
WHAT'S NEW WHAT WE CAN DO
BETTER AND OBVIOUSLY HOW WE
COULD TAKE THE LARGEST. THAT WE
HAVE. OF THE- CORRECTION
DEPARTMENT AND MAKE IT AN
EFFECTIVE SYSTEM. SO THAT WHEN
YOU ENTERED COME OUT BETTER.
AND WE GET OUR FIRST PANELIST
BECAUSE ARE LISTED IN SPEAKING
ORDER NUMBER THAT ASK EACH ONE
OF THEM TO BRIEFLY INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES BEFORE THEY SPEAK.
UP AND WILL WILL START WITH THE
FIRST PANEL. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS KATHLEEN
ALISON NINE THE UNDERSECRETARY
OF OPERATIONS FOR CBC ARE.
VALUE COMPASS IS A LOT OF STUFF
OF BASICALLY THE DAY TO DAY
PRISON OPERATIONS AS WELL AS
PAROLE I CAN SAY THAT I'M PROUD
OF BEEN PART OF THE EVOLUTION.
I'VE BEEN IN THIS DEPARTMENT A
VERY LONG TIME AND I'VE SEEN A
LOT OF THINGS CHANGE OVER THE
OVER THE YEARS. IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX WE PUT REHABILITATION
LEARNING AND UNFORTUNATELY SO
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT WE LOST ALL
THE- LARGE PORTION OF THE
FUNDING FOR WE- SINCE THAT TIME
THANKS TO LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION. WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO REBUILD OUR REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAM TO WHERE THEY'RE
MEANINGFUL PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM AND A REALLY MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
EVERY SINGLE DAY. TO BE A PART
OF THAT EVOLUTION BUT PART OF
THE EVOLUTION OF ARE SHE
REFORMS OF SOME FROM LITIGATION
AND SOME INDEPENDENTLY WE CHOSE
TO CHANGE OUR OUR MATRIX FOR
SECURITY HOUSING WHAT PENALTIES
GET YOU THERE WE INDIVIDUALLY
THAT THAT. WE CUT THAT
POPULATION. HELLO HELLO. YEAH
AUTONOMOUS ALL OVER INDIA. WE
FORTUNATELY. THAT POPULATION IN
HALF AND IS THERE MORE TO DO I
THINK THERE IS AND IT'S THINGS
THAT WE CERTAINLY LOOK AT OUR
CLASSIFICATION SYSTEM TO SEE
WHAT OUR OTHER CHANGES WERE WE
DO WE'RE LOOKING OUT OUR
RECEPTION CENTER PROCESSING TO
STREAMLINE THE TIME IT TAKES TO
GO THROUGH A RECEPTION CENTER
PROCESSING. TO GET PEOPLE TO
PROGRAMS GET INTO INSTITUTIONS
WHERE THEY CAN PROGRAM BEEN
VERY FORTUNATE. THAT THIS
DEPARTMENT HAS EMBRACED THE
VARIOUS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORMS THAT WE'VE HAD OVER THE
YEARS RIGHT WAS STARTED
REALIGNMENT SUBSEQUENT TO
REALIGNMENT WE HAD PROPOSITION
THIRTY SIX FORTY SEVEN I HAD
THE PLEASURE LEADING THOSE
EFFORTS UP IN MY PRIOR POSITION
AND IN THE DIFFERENCE AT THAT
MADE THE VERY YOUTHFUL OFFENDER
BILLS. HAVE EMBRACED IT WE'VE
BEEN BRACED TO THE POINT OF
UTILIZING A SECTION OF OUR
PENAL CODE. THAT AFFORDS US AN
OPPORTUNITY MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS BACK TO THE
COURTS FOR RE SENTENCING. WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD THAT ABILITY BUT I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU I'VE
RARELY IF EVER SAW A RECALL OF.
NOW WE'VE HAD HUNDREDS OF
INMATES REFERRED BACK TO THE
COURTS FOR RECALL OF SENTENCE.
THAT'S HUGE THAT'S US PUTTING
OUR NAME ON SOMEBODY SAYING
YEAH WE THINK THAT WE ASK THE
COURT TO RE EVALUATE. AND WE'VE
SEEN OVERWHELMING NOT ALL
COUNTIES NOT ALL JUDGES BUT WE
HAVE SEEN SUPPORT FOR THAT AND
SO WE'RE HOPEFUL IN THE FUTURE
AS WE FINALIZE SOME REGULATIONS
SO THERE'S VERY SPECIFIC
CRITERIA AND EVERYBODY KNOWS
SECRETARY. SO IT'S NOT A YOU
KNOW WHAT'S THE CRITERIA
EVERYBODY WILL KNOW WE WILL BE
IN TO REGULATIONS. WE HOPE TO
EXPAND FURTHER ON SOME OF OUR
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER PROGRAMMING
YOU KNOW THERE WAS LEGISLATION
COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT AFFORDED
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO PLACE
YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS AND LOWER
LEVELS. WERE LOWER LEVELS
WITHOUT PROGRAMMING. DIDN'T A
LOT IT SAID GUYS FROM BEING A
LEVEL FOUR BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO GO FURTHER. AND WE ARE
WE HAVE EXPANDED OUR EDUCATION
PROGRAMS IMMENSELY WE HAVE FACE
TO FACE COLLAGEN EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF OUR PRISON. WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF INSTITUTIONS I HAVE
FOR YOUR PROGRAMS. UCLA OFFERS
A AT LA SEE THROUGH PELL GRANT
FOUR YEAR COLLEGE DEGREE
PROGRAM. AND WE HAD SOME
INMATES GRADUATE WITH A FOUR
YEAR DEGREE OTHERS CAN GET THEM
THROUGH COAST LINE CALL.
TUITION VERSES A PATH SO WE
KNOW WE LONG WAY TO GO IN THAT
AREA A LOT OF OUR VERY HIGH
LEVEL SKILLED VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS OUR ACCOUNT. OUR
CODING FOR CUTTING PROGRAM.
BUILDING PROGRAMS ARE WATER
RUNNING PROGRAMS I MEAN THERE'S
NUMEROUS PROGRAMS OUT THERE
THAT THE INTENT OF THEM IS TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN SOMEBODY'S
LIFE I HAD THE PLEASURE OF JUST
THIS PAST WEEK ATTENDING A
GRADUATION FOR WHAT WE CALL OUR
PRINTER TRAINS AND- SO THAT ARE
GO ABOUT IS A FIRE CAMP SO IT
MADE SURE FIRE CAMP COULD APPLY
TO GO TO THE THEATER TRAINS IN
OUR SUPPORT. THEY'RE PAID TO BE
THERE BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION. WE'VE HAD SIXTY
FIVE GRADUATES OF THAT PROGRAM
SOME OF WHICH YOU ALREADY
WORKING FOR CALIFORNIA SO I WAS
SPEAKING IN AT NOON. ON ON.
FRIDAY AND THEY WERE ACTIVATED
IMMEDIATELY UPON GRADUATION TO
THE LA FIRES SO THAT IS
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM RIGHT
THAT IS REALLY HAVE A QUICK TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE ALL FEEL
VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THAT. IT'S
WORKING FOR THE PART. THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DON
SPECTER ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE WE'RE BASED IN BERKELEY.
YEAH BOY. A STAFF OF ABOUT
TWENTY AND OUR MISSION IS TO
PROVIDE A LEGAL AT THAT. LIVE
IT UP. AND SO I AM HERE TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE DIFFERENT VIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT AND THEN YOU
JUST. AT THE KNOWS. SO START BY
TALKING ABOUT THE FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUE MY. YES MY. SO I'M DONE
SPECTER I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
PRISON LAW OFFICE SO I'M HERE
TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE DIFFERENT
VIEW OF THE ISSUES WE SEE
FACING CORRECTIONS AND THE BASE
MOST BASIC VIEW ISSUE FACING
CORRECTIONS IS THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE AT IN ITS
PRISONS WE HAVE A PRISON SYSTEM
DESIGNED FOR ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND AS YOU JUST
HEARD THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THAT WE BROUGHT A CASE MANY
YEARS AGO THAT WENT TO THE
SUPREME COURT THAT CAP PRISON
POPULATION AT A HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN POINT 5% OF ITS DESIGN
PASSIVITY AN- APARTMENT HAS
THROUGH. INITIATIVES IN SOME
LEGISLATION BEEN ABLE TO MEET
THAT CAP. BUT I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR. TO PANEL AND YOU WILL
MANY OF WHOM. PROBABLY KNOW
THIS BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
PRISONS WHO WERE WITH WHICH
YOU'RE WAY OVER THAT DESIGN
CAPACITY. THERE ARE TEN PERSONS
WHICH YOU'RE OVER THE COURT
ORDERED CAP NOT. THE CAP WAS
DESIGNED FOR THE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE SO THAT I DON'T WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THEY'RE NOT
VIOLATING A COURT ORDER. JUST
TO GIVE YOU SOME PERSPECTIVE.
PRISONS ARE OVER A HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN POINT 5% FOR
SIXTY PERCENT. AND THE HIGHEST
PRISON IS AT A HUNDRED AND 73%
OF DESIGN CAPACITY THAT'S THE-
PRISON AT SOLANO. IN MY OPINION
UNTIL THE STATE AND THE
DEPARTMENT GETS A HANDLE ON ON
REDUCING THE- UP PRISON
POPULATION. MANY OF THE EFFORTS
THAT KATHY WANTS TO SUCCEED AND
WE HAVE TO LITIGATE. YEAH.
TWENTY OR THIRTY YEARS WHAT
WON'T GET FIXED THERE ARE
SIMPLY TOO MANY PEOPLE CONFINED
IN SMALL SPACES AND THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES NECESSARY
TO NOT ONLY KEEP THEM SAFE
PREVENT THEM FROM GETTING SICK
OR DYING BUT ALSO YOU IT'S
REALLY HARD TO REHABILITATE
SOMEBODY IN AN INSTITUTION
WHICH IS NOT SAFE AND WHICH IS
NOT PROVIDING THE PROCREATE
SERVICES AND YOU IT'S REALLY
HARD TO REHABILITATE SOMEBODY
IN SUCH MASSIVE PRISON. IS
THERE AN I. T. PERSON IN THE
HOUSE OKAY VERY GO. SO OVER IT
I WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT THAT'S-
YOU KNOW MY IF THERE IS GOING
TO BE IN AN EFFORT TO REFORM
THE PRISON SYSTEM MY ENERGIES
WOULD BE ON REDUCING THE
POPULATION BECAUSE THAT THAT
INHIBITS EVERYTHING FROM THAT
KATHY WAS TRYING TO DO FROM.
FROM BECOMING A REALITY AND I
WANT TO TALK TO AN- A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT. OUR CASE THAT
INVOLVED THE FAILURE OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE MENTALLY
ILL SERVICES AND HOW THAT INTO
RELATES WITH THE PRISON CAP THE
SERVER SIDE RATE AS YOU MIGHT
HAVE READ IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE ARTICLE JUST A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO. IS THAT A
HISTORICALLY HIGH RATES RALPH
THE AS THE SECRETARY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
MENTIONED THAT IT'S A SUICIDE
CRISIS IT'S A TWENTY SIX POINT
THREE PEOPLE COMMIT SUICIDE OUT
OF EVERY HUNDRED AND THOUSANDS.
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN PRISON
THAT'S ABOUT THE HIGHEST AMONG
MANY PRISON POPULOUS PRESENTS
LARGE PRISON SYSTEMS IN THE
COUNTRY. AND IT'S HAPPENING
DESPITE THE OVER TWENTY YEARS
OF LITIGATION. OVER EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE A SUICIDE QUESTIONS AND
JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
MENTALLY ILL POPULATION THE
POPULATION. SINCE WE REDUCE THE
POPULATION FROM A HIGH OF A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS BUT NOT WITHOUT HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND. PEOPLE IN
PRISON WHEN WE FILED THE
OVERCROWDING CASE TO WHAT IT IS
NOW THERE ARE THREE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED MORE MENTALLY ILL
PEOPLE IN THE SYSTEM THAN THERE
WERE WHEN WE STARTED THAT CASE.
AND A MUCH HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE IN PRISON AS- A AS A
MATTER OF FACT YOU KNOW AS OF
AUGUST OF THIS YEAR THERE WERE
TWENTY EIGHT OR 29% OF THE
PRISON POPULATION HAD A MEN
ONLY MENTAL ILLNESS DIAGNOSIS.
SO WE ARE REALLY TURNING THAT
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS INTO
TWO INTO A PLACE WHICH HOUSES
PEOPLE WITH LIFE SENTENCES AND
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS. AND
AS A RESULT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
TREATMENT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DESPITE ITS- EFFORTS
WHICH I DON'T THINK HAVE BEEN
AS ALICE'S THEY COULD BE. FIND
ENOUGH. PHYSICIAN OR
PSYCHIATRISTS TO TREAT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THEY HAVE AN
MENTAL ILLNESS SO IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR SYSTEMIC REFORMS I
THINK YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
RATE AT WHICH WE INCARCERATE
PEOPLE WITH MENTALLY ILL AND
PROVIDE COMMUNITY GRAMS WHICH
ARE MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE AND
MUCH CHEAPER THAN SENDING. A
PEOPLE WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS TO
PRISON. THE OTHER. SYSTEM WIDE.
PROBLEM THAT'S FACING
CORRECTIONS IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT EXISTS IN
THE PRISONS IT WOULD IT'S NOT
AN EXAGGERATION TO SAY THAT THE
PUT SOME OF THE PRISONS ARE
LITERALLY FALLING APART THERE
ARE HOLES IN THE ROOFS OF WINGS
OF PRISONS HOUSING UNITS OF
PRISONS HAVE TO BE REPLACED
CAPTIONS HAVE TO BE REPLACED IF
YOU GO TO THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR MEN YOU'LL SEE
A THIRD WORLD PLUMBING SYSTEM.
AND WELL HAS BEEN AN
ACCELERATED BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
OVER CROWDED SO WHAT IS WHAT
WAS DESIGNED FOR A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IT'S BEEN IT'S
LIKE IF YOU LIVED IN YOUR HOUSE
AND YOU'RE INVITED TEN PEOPLE
TO SHARE A FOR. A FOUR PERSON
HOUSE. ALL THE SYSTEMS THAT
THAT HOUSE HAS TO OPERATE WOULD
DETERIORATE FASTER AND THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENED BECAUSE OF
OVERCROWDING. SO TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF HOW. EXPENSIVE THIS IS
AND HOW. THE BASE OF IT IS THE
DEPARTMENT TO ITS AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ITS CREDIT IT
INITIATED THE STUDY BY THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO WHO BUILT MANY OF
THE PRISONS TO DETERMINE WHAT
NEEDS TO BE REPAIRED IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM. AND THEY LOOKED
AT THE CALIFORNIA MEN'S
FACILITY IT BACK TO BILL AND
THEY FOUND THAT. IT WILL COST
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS JUST TO BRING
THAT UP. PRISON UP TO STANDARDS
AND THAT WOULD BE FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
REPLACE A SEVERAL HOUSING UNITS
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS PER LAYS A BUNCH OF
OTHER HOUSING UNITS. HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO REPLACE A BUNCH OF OTHER
HOUSING UNITS AND THAT'S NOT
COUNTING THE KITCHEN AND
ADMINISTRATIVE AREAS SO THAT'S
ONE ISSUE THAT IS HOVERING OVER
THE DEPARTMENT IS THAT THERE
THESE FACILITIES ESSENTIALLY
ARE NOT SAFE AND- TO BRING
THAT. POINT HOME. WE LITIGATED
A CASE AT THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FACILITY IN CORCORAN
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THAT OF.
YEAH CAT THESE ALMA MATER. AND
THE REASON WE LITIGATED THE
CASES BECAUSE A PRISONER WROTE
TO US AND SAID EATING IN THE
DINING HALL WHERE THERE'S A
HOLE IN THE ROOF AND AS YOU
KNOW IN CALIFORNIA IT RAINS.
AND SO THE RAIN WOULD COME AND
BECAUSE WELL THE ROOF IS
FAILING AND THE RAIN WOULD WELL
I READ YOU WHAT THE COURT SAID
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS TO THAT. TWO
PRISONERS WHO ARE EATING AT IN
THAT DINING HALL. IT'S A SHAME
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
HAVE A LOT OF THE FIST THE
EIGHT DOT ALL. ALL IN SUCH A
STATE OF DISREPAIR. THE
EVIDENCE PAINTS A PICTURE OF A
CORRECTIONAL DINING BILL THE
LONG NEGLECTED OF BASIC HOUSING
MAINTENANCE THAT IS NOW
IRRECONCILABLE WITH LOOKING XIN.
IN THE NATION AND OF SUCH
FINANCIAL UPON. THE BILL HAS.
THE EXPERT WE HIRED IN THAT
CASE EXAMINE THE ROOF HE'S HE'S
EXAMINED THE THOUSAND ROOFS AND
FOUND THAT WAS THE WORST HE'S
EVER SEEN HE TESTIFIED THAT THE
ROOFING FAILURES CREATE QUOTE A
PATHWAY OF RAIN WATER MAKES
PC'S THAT FLOWS DOWNWARD IN THE
ARCHITECTURAL SYSTEMS AND INTO
THE DINING ROOM. BELOW. HE ALL
AND THE COURT FOUND THAT
CEILING TILES SATURATED WITH
THIS WATER POSE A SUBSTANTIAL
RISK OF FALLING ON INMATES.
CAUSING THEM EITHER PHYSICAL
INJURY FROM THE IMPACT OF
PLACING THEM IN DIRECT CONTACT
WITH FECAL MATTER AND MOLD ON A
SEPARATE OCCASION AMOUNTS FELL
INTO THE DINING ROOM TABLE FROM
THE CEILING. AND EVEN WHEN IT'S
NOT RAINING THE EVIDENCE
ESTABLISHES THAT INMATES ARE
SEATED AT TABLES UNDER EXPOSED
CEILING FROM WHICH MICE AND
MAGGOTS FALL DURING MEAL TIME.
AND THE TOP ALL THAT OFF THIS
IS A CASE THAT WENT TO
LITIGATION THE DEPARTMENT KNEW
ABOUT IT WE REYES. IT WAS A
WRIT OF HABEAS CORPUS THE
PERSON WHO BROUGHT THIS CASE
FILE THE ADMINISTRATIVE APPEAL
TO GET THIS PROBLEM RESOLVED.
THEY GRANTED HIS APPEAL BUT THE
PROBLEM AND WE HAVE A LITIGATE
THIS AND IT TOOK ACTUALLY EVEN
AFTER WE WON. THE CASE IN THE
COURT IT TOOK THE PERSONAL
INTERVENTION OF SECRETARY DS
THAT WE CLOSE THE DINING HALL
UNTIL THE. PROBLEM WAS
CORRECTED SO. IN CONCLUSION.
POPULATION ISSUES
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES AND THE
NUMBER OF MENTALLY ILL WHO WERE
IN THE PRISON SYSTEM ARE THE
ISSUES THAT I HOPE. YOU ALL AND
THE LEGISLATURE IN FRONT OF THE
COMING YEAR. YEAH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAITLYN O'NEILL WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I'M GOING TO BE WORKING
FROM A HAND OUT CALLED PLANNING
FOR THE DECLINING INMATE
POPULATION FOR MY REMARKS ON
BOTH PANEL ONE IN PANEL TO
WHICH YOU SHOULD HAVE AND I
BELIEVE THERE ARE MAYBE EXTRA
COPIES IF ANYONE NEEDS ONE. AND
I'M GOING TO FIRST PRESENTS
PROJECTIONS OF WHERE THEY MAY
POPULATION IS THAT IT OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS ADD PROVIDE SOME
BRIEF BACKGROUND ON THE COURT
ORDERED LIMITS ON PRISON
OVERCROWDING AS WELL AS
DISCUSSED SOME APPROACHES THAT
THE STATE COULD TAKE TO REDUCE
CAPACITY AS- POPULATION DECLINE.
WHICH IS A LITTLE FOR YOUR NEXT
PAGE. ONE YOU SEE IF YOU CAN
SEE THE- ON ON PAGE ONE SHOWS
THAT THE STATE INMATE
POPULATION THE OVERALL IN THE
POPULATION IS PRETTY. ACTED TO
DECLINE OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS. SPECIFICALLY BY AN
ESTIMATED SIXTY EIGHT HUNDRED
INMATES BY JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AND IF THE CLIENT
MERRILY AHEAD DUE TO THE IMPACT
OF PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN
WHICH WAS APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND I
MADE CERTAIN NONVIOLENT
OFFENDERS ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE
CONSIDERATION AS WELL AS
AUTHORIZED AND OR EXPANDED CDC
ARE THE THIRTY TO REDUCE
INMATES TERMS THEIR CREDITS.
AND THEN I WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE
THAT THESE PROJECTIONS YOU SEE
IN THE FIGURE HERE REFLECT
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE MADE TO THE
MINISTRY MOST RECENT POPULATION
PROJECTIONS. ACCOUNT FOR THEM
OUR MOST RECENT MONTHS OF
ACTUAL DATA AS WELL AS THE
EFFECTS OF SOME MILLION ACTED
SENSING CHANGES. TURN THE PAGE
TO PAGE TWO AND I'M GOING TO
PROVIDE SOME BACKGROUND ON THE
FEDERAL COURT ORDERED PRISON
POPULATION CAP. MORE
SPECIFICALLY CDC ARE IS
REQUIRED TO LIMIT PRISON
OVERCROWDING BY KEEPING THE
POPULATION OF ITS THIRTY FOUR
STATE OWN PRISONS TO UNDER
ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
INMATES. AND TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE DOESN'T EXCEED THAT CAP
CDC ARE MAINTAINS A POPULATION
TYPICALLY OF A COUPLE THOUSAND
INMATES LESS THAN A HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND. AND IN THE
THIRTY FOUR PRESENCE IN ORDER
TO BUFFER AGAINST UNEXPECTED
INCREASES IN THE POPULATION AND
AVOID TO AVOID EXCEEDING THAT
THE COURT ORDER. AND I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT INMATES THAT THE
STATE DOES HOUSE IN MADE
OUTSIDE OF THE THIRTY FOUR
STATE OWNED AND OPERATED
PRISONS TO AVOID EXCEEDING THE
CAP BECAUSE THE OVERALL
POPULATION IS HIGHER THAN THAT
CURRENTLY HIGHER THAN A HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND. SO AND AS
OF OCTOBER NINTH CDC OUR HOUSE
ABOUT FOURTEEN HUNDRED MALE
INMATES AND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FEMALE INMATES AND PRIVATE
PRIVATELY OPERATED CONTRACT
FACILITIES. AND ABOUT SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED MALE INMATES IN
PUBLICLY OPERATED CONTRACT
FACILITIES AND ABOUT SIXTY
SEVEN HUNDRED INMATES IN
VARIOUS OTHER PLACEMENT.
INCLUDING CONSERVATION CAMPS.
MOVING ON TO PAGE THREE. I'M
GOING TO DISCUSS SOME
APPROACHES FOR ACCOMMODATING
THE PROJECTED DECLINE IN THE
INMATE POPULATION. EXISTING
STATE LAW REQUIRES CDC OUR
FIRST TO REMOVE ALL IN ME ALL
MALE INMATES FROM PRIVATELY
OPERATED CONTRACT PRISONS WHICH
IS IN PROCESS THE STATE DID
REMOVE INMATES FROM ONE OF
THREE OF THOSE FACILITIES LAST
MONTH AS AS A POPULATION. HAS
BEEN DECLINING. STATE LAW THEN
ARTHRITIS CDC ARE TO DETERMINE
HOW TO ACCOMMODATE FURTHER
DECLINES IN THE POPULATION BUT
REQUIRES CDC ARE TO CONSIDER
CERTAIN CRITERIA SUCH AS COST
AS WELL AS GENDER SPECIFIC
HOUSING NEEDS. AND REGARDING
BOYS ABOUT HOW TO REDUCE
CAPACITY IN LINE WITH THE
PROJECTED DECLINES OF IN THE
PRISON POPULATION. WE THINK
THAT CLOSING STATE OPERATED
PRISONS WOULD LIKELY ALLOW FOR
THE GREATEST SAVINGS. ALTHOUGH
THERE ARE OF COURSE OTHER
CRITERIA THAT SHOULD SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED AND SO ON THAT POINT
AND AFTER. THE STATE REMOVES
THE ABOUT FOURTEEN HUNDRED
INMATES FROM THE MAIL PRIVATE
PRIVATELY OPERATED CONTACT AS
HOUSING MALES AS IS REQUIRED BY
STATE LAW. AND THE PROJECTIONS
SUGGEST THAT THERE WILL BE A
REMAINING REDUCTION OF ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED INMATES BY
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY THREE THAT
WILL STILL NEED TO BE
ACCOMMODATED. AND SO THERE'S
VARIOUS WAYS THAT THIS COULD BE
IT THIS REDUCTION COULD BE
ACCOMMODATED. AND THE THREE
THREE WAYS THREE MAIN WAYS AND
ARE WHAT I'M GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING HERE TODAY THE FIRST
IS TO CLOSE THEY OPERATED
PRISONS AND WITH THAT A ROUGHLY
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED AND MEET
DECLINE THE STATE COULD CLOSE
BOTH THE SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZED. PRESENT AT AND WHICH WE
ESTIMATE WOULD YIELD ROUGHLY A
FEW HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ANNUAL SAVINGS. I'M AN ADDITION
WHEN A PRISON IS BOTH THE
PENDING ON THE PRESIDENT THEY
COULD ALSO. TO AVOID COSTLY
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
NECESSARY TO CONTINUE OP THE
PRESENT. THE SECOND APPROACH
WOULD BE TO PUT A PRIORITIZE
ELIMINATING THE REMAIN CONTRACT
BEDS. AND SO AS I MENTIONED
AFTER THE FOURTEEN HUNDRED
HOUSING MALES AND PRIVATELY
OPERATED FACILITIES ARE REMOVED
THERE'S WOULD STILL BE OUT TO
HUNT TWO THOUSAND INMATES LEFT
IN CONTRACT FACILITIES. AND SO
IF THE STATE CHOSE TO REMOVE
INMATES FROM THOSE FACILITIES.
IT WHAT WE ESTIMATE THAT GIVEN
THE SIZE OF THE POPULATION
DECLINE IT COULD STILL CLOSE
AND MEDIUM SIZED PRISON. IN
DOING SO DOING THESE TWO
ACTIONS TOGETHER WE ESTIMATE
WOULD SAVE AROUND A COUPLE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. AND FINALLY THE THIRD
APPROACH THAT I WILL MENTION
HERE TODAY WOULD BE SIMPLY TO
ALLOW THE POPULATION OF TO
MAINTAIN CONTRACTS MEAN TEEN
OPERATION OF ALL THE PRISONS
BUT JUST ALLOW THE POPULATION
OF THE- F. THIRTY FOUR STATE
OWNED AND OPERATED PRISONS. TO
DECLINE AS THE INMATE
POPULATION DECLINES IN OTHER
WORDS OPERATING PRISONS LESS
DENSELY AND WE ESTIMATE THAT
THAT APPROACH WOULD YIELD TOTAL
OPERATIONAL SAVINGS ON IN THE
SEVERAL TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. AND I WILL
RETURN TO THE HAND OUT FOR
PANEL. OVER TO HOLD MY COMMENTS
THERE AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS
. OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME
ALL RIGHT SO I USED TO BE
DIRECTOR WILL STAY SO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS. CUT ABOVE MY
THING AND I KNOW AND PUBLIC
SECTOR WE DON'T DO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OVERALL NOT JUST
CDC ARE AND YOU'RE MENTIONING
SOME. RENT IS THINGS ARE GOING
ON AND I IN A WAY TO ONE. OTHER
FACILITIES WHERE THEY HAVE NO
AIR CONDITIONING AND IT CAN GET
UPWARDS TO A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN DEGREES OUTSIDE AND
PART OF IT YOU RAISED A LOT OF
THE INFORMATION FROM THE TRACK.
QUAL DURING THE DAY AND THEN
THEY GO TO SLEEP. AT NIGHT SO
THAT THEY CAN CRAWL BUT IT'S A
AND HAVE SWAMPED BANDS AND
THINGS THAT NATURE BUT NO ONE'S
EVER REALLY ADDRESSING MAYBE
JUST GET SOME AIR CONDITIONING.
BUT IT'S ALSO VERY COST
PROHIBITIVE. SO. YOUR YOUR NAME
AND ALL THAT ARE YOU KIND OF
SAME WE SHOULD GO AND MAYBE GO
TO PUBLIC AND GET A BOND AND
TRY TO REBUILD A READ AND OFF
THE FINANCES OVER SQUIRMING
RIGHT NOW BUT EACH WEEK SO WE
THINK ABOUT A COUPLE OF BONDING
PROGRAM TO. REHABILITATE OUR
BUILDING SO THAT THEY FIT IN
LINE WITH THE NEW
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THAT
WERE DESIGNING. SO THAT NOT BE.
REFERS TO BUILD AND BRING THEM
UP TO STANDARD BUT WE DESIGNED
A MAST SIDE SO THAT THEY- KIND
OF THE COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR ANY
OTHER THINGS THAT WE WANT TO DO.
YEAH I DON'T REALLY CARE WHERE
YOU GET THE MONEY. I'M NOT A
MONEY ISSUE YEAH I KNOW I KNOW
BUT YEAH IT'S- IS NOT ONLY
UNCOMFORTABLE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE AIR CONDITIONING BUT
IT'S ALSO DANGEROUS IT MAKES
PEOPLE SICK AND IT'S A MATTER
OF ACTUAL. YOU KNOW. WILL SAVE
A AND FREE FROM DISEASE. AND SO
YES I THINK YOU KNOW YOU'RE
LOOKING AT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
JUST ONE PRISON. HONEY BUT IT'S
REAL MONEY AND IT'S GOING TO
COST A LOT OF AND THEY WILL LET
MORE THAT THEY'VE STUDIED AND
WE'RE WAITING FOR THOSE REPORTS
TO COME OUT AND I GUESS IS THE
RELATIVELY SIMILAR. AND SO
YOU'RE LOOKING AT I DON'T MY
MATHIS BET THAT'S WHICH IS WHY
I'M NOT MONEY GUY BUT YOU'RE
LOOKING A LOT OF MONEY IN ORDER
TO DO THIS SO. MY SUGGESTION
WOULD BE TO PRIORITIZE THE
THING THAT I DID. THE REAL
ESTATE AND THE PROPERTIES WHICH
ARE AT THEM BECAUSE THE MOST
HARTMAN THERE ARE. PUT IT YES
BOTH END UP YOUR INCARCERATED
TO FIX THOSE IN THAT SOME
SOMEWHAT OF ON SOMEWHAT OF A
QUICK SCHEDULE BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THERE'S NO PLAN AT ALL.
THANK YOU
. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER SO QUICK QUESTION TO ALL
THREE PANELISTS I THINK THE
UNDERSECRETARY. DESCRIBED A-
SOME OF THE REHABILITATION
OPTIONS I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THAT IN ORDER TO REALLY ENSURE
THE POPULATION GOES DOWN BE
ABILITY ASIANS GRANT TO BE DONE
BETTER PROBABLY MORE
STRATEGICALLY AND WITH CLEAR
RESULTS SUGGEST FOR REQUESTED
UNDERSECRETARY BUT LOVE THE
COMMENTS FROM LA AS WELL AS-
WHICH IS BETTER IS. I'M NOT
NOTHING YOU HAVE. THE CLASSES
IN PLACE IN THE FUTURE I KNOW
THE SNAPPING DONE YET IN THE
FUTURE HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
EVALUATE SUCCESS MANAGEMENT IN
MAY IN MAY PERSPECTIVE HOW WILL
YOU KNOW. BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
THE L. L. IN MISTER SPECTER
COULD TURN IN THE PAPER TO.
WELL WE HAVE A LOT OF
INITIATIVE SO. REHABILITATION
IS YOU KNOW WAS WAS ONE OF OUR
KEY. KEY MISSIONS OF OUR
DEPARTMENT AND SO FOCUSING
THOSE ENERGIES REAR THE PROCESS
OF REEVALUATING THE MODEL ON
HOW WE- HOW EDUCATION IS
DELIVERED AND WHAT TIME FRAMES
TO MAXIMIZE UTILIZATION OF THE
CLASSROOM SPACE AS WELL AS A
VERY STREET IN SPACES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED WITH OUR
FURTHER EXPANSION OF OUR-
INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT MODEL THAT IS GET
READY TO ROLL OUT IN JANUARY.
OF WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH ON
THE OFFICE OF RESEARCH AS WELL
AS THE PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE WE'VE SIGNED SOME
AGREEMENTS WITH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TO BE ABLE TO TRACK
OUTCOMES. IN IN SOME WAYS TO
SEE. OUR OFFENDERS ABLE TO GET
REAL JOBS RIGHT REAL JOBS IN
TRADES REAL JOBS YOU KNOW WE I
KNOW WE'RE FOCUSING ON THESE
THE FIRE GUYS THAT ARE GOING
OUT SO WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
BE DONE THERE AND EXACT. HELLO
I'M NOT THE PROJECT FOR. WHO'S
JUST SO WE KNOW WE KNOW WHO'S
IN. CHARGE OF DEVELOPING THAT
TRACKING IN THAT MEASUREMENT.
SO IT VARIES PEOPLE HAVE
DIFFERENT PIECES SO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THE PRISON
TO IMPLEMENT HAVE THEIR PEACE
FOR VERY SPECIFIC TRADES. FOR
LIKE THE WHAT A WELDING TRADER
CARPENTER TRAITS OF THOSE TYPE
OF THINGS I KNOW DEAR PEAS
WORKING ON SOME INITIATIVES AND
MISTRESSES AGAIN SPEAK TO THAT
AND THEN OF COURSE OUR OFFICE
OF RESEARCH IS PARTNERING UP TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE BEST WAY.
GOING FORWARD. WHAT THE WHAT
HOW HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE
THE GOAL WHAT WITH THE GOAL OF
THE OF THOSE VARIOUS
INITIATIVES. THESE ARE MY WORDS
SO. IT'S. I WOULD THINK TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
BASS TO GIVE US THE BIGGEST
BANG FOR OUR BUCK MEANING AND
ALL USE ONE OF OUR PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE ARE UNDERWATER WELDING
THIS GUY'S OF THE CORD TO PA
HAS RECIDIVISM. OUR CODING
PROGRAM. LOW IF ANY WERE
SERVICE AT RIGHT RATE SO THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR THE BUCK FOR
THOSE TYPE OF PROGRAMS. TO FOUR
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY BE
SUCCESSFUL. YEAH. UHHUH. YEAH
SURE. UHHUH OUR. THAT'S FAIR I
MEAN INFRASTRUCTURE LIMITS.
THIS IS OUR NUMBER ONE
CHALLENGE IN OUR DEPARTMENT.
PHYSICAL PLANT AS FAR AS WHAT
INSTITUTIONS ARE BUILT WITH
WHAT KIND OF PROGRAMMING SPACE
AND IT ALL OFTENTIMES HAS TO DO
WITH THE TIME THAT THEY'RE
BUILT RIGHT CTF FOR EXAMPLE OR
CALIFORNIA TRADE FACILITY IT
WAS BUILT AT A TIME. WHERE
REHABILITATION WAS PART OF THE
GAME THEY HAVE LOTS OF PROGRAM
SPACE I WOULD ALSO PRESENT LOTS
OF PROGRAM SPACE SO IT JUST
REALLY KIND OF DEPENDS UPON
EACH INSTITUTION I WISH I COULD
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE LET'S SAY
WELDING I WISH I COULD HAVE
EVER CIVIL PRISON. AND EVERY
SINGLE YARD I MIGHT HAVE A ONE
YOUR BUT NOT ANOTHER YARD SO I
MEAN WE DO HAVE A CHALLENGE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE FAIR
NEXT LITTLE PROGRAMS RATHER
INSTITUTIONS. THAT'S WHAT YOU
AND I VISITED SALINAS VALLEY
JUST A FEW TO GO NUTS WILL BE.
WE NOTICE RIGHT YOU'RE AT. A
FIVE A PRETTY AMAZING WELDING
PROGRAM ONE YARD. BUT THE OTHER
THREE YARDS COULDN'T. ACCESS
THAT PROGRAM EVEN THOUGH IS
JUST A FEW. FIGURE OUT HOW DO
WE- LEVERAGE THAT AMAZING
RESOURCES READY AT THE FACILITY.
HOUSE ACCESS TO. HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS NOW TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN. MAXIMIZE
UTILIZATION THE SPACE THE
PROGRAM. WELL THERE ARE TWO
SIMPLE ANSWERS PROBABLY WHICH
YOU KNOW OUR ANYONE IS A USE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS ONLY OR
TWO IF YOU'RE GONNA USE NON
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS THEY
SHOULD COME WITH THEY SHOULD BE
CUT PAIRED WITH MONEY TO ALLOW
THEM TO BE EVALUATED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY'RE
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT AND THE THIRD
THING WHICH OF OFTEN IS THE
HARDEST IS TO GET RID OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT PEOPLE FEEL GOOD
ABOUT. THAT ARE NOT EFFECTIVE.
GEN OF JUVENILE JUSTICE HAS
COME A LONG WAY IN DOING THAT
THEY SO I KNOW IT CAN BE DONE
AS TO YOUR- COMMENT ABOUT SCALE.
YEAH THAT'S THE MAIN PROBLEM
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
UNDER WATER WELDERS OR HOW MANY
FISH. YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
TRAIN ON OUR WELDERS ARE THEY
HAVE A HORSE PROGRAM AND SEE I
AM. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
HANDFUL OF PEOPLE IN A SEA OF.
PEOPLE HUNDRED OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE SO. I THINK.
YOU KNOW IF I WERE. IN CHECKING
AS SOMEBODY. HE SAID. I WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT THEY DO OFFER OFFER THEM
TO THE MOST NUMBER OF PEOPLE
AVAILABLE AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT. THAT I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THAT CRITERIA HAS BEEN IN
EFFECT OR NOT. WE HAVE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE STATE
CONTRACT WITH EXTERNAL
RESEARCHERS TO CONDUCT COST
EFFECTIVENESS STUDIES OF CDC
OUR REHABILITATION PROGRAMS AND
MY COLLEAGUE PLANS TO DESCRIBE
THAT. ON THE THIRD PANEL. YEAH
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
SUSPECT I'M SURE YOU WHERE WE
HAVE WE LOOK INTO THE ISSUE OF.
OBVIOUSLY MAINTENANCE REPAIR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND OUR
PRISONS WE'VE BEEN GIVEN THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE IN
PICTURES AS WELL AS A HUGE
LEAKS AND- WROTE SOME THINGS
THAT ARE FALLING APART. ONE OF
THINGS WERE GRAPPLING WITH AND
I GUESS IT SHOULD COME MAY COME
FROM CDC OURS THAT WE ARE AS WE
TALK ABOUT THE DECLINE IN THE
POPULATION AND WE HOPE TO.
QUESTION BECOMES ONCE IF WE'RE
DECLINE. WE ARE HAPPY TO BE AND
I WANT TO BE THEN HOW DO WE
PLAN AND MANAGE THE POPULATIONS
REMAINS SO WHO CAN GET TO A
POINT. IN A PRISON. TO PRE
INTEGRATE X. AMOUNT OF SAVINGS.
THE ONE THING WE FEAR IS THAT
WE DON'T WANT TO PUT. SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
INTO REPAIRING A PRISON THAT WE
TEAR DOWN THE NEXT DAY. SO
THAT'S THAT'S A REAL CONCERN
AND SO WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
GRAPPLE WITH THE PRIORITY LIST.
OF IF WE REDUCE THE POPULATION
WHAT. SHOULD WE KEEP AND THAT'S
A HOT POLITICAL ISSUE CAUSES IT
SOME PEOPLE'S AREAS AND MAYBE
LIKE PRISONS BECAUSE IT CREATES
JOBS. SO WE'VE BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH HOW DO YOU HOW DO WE
DEFINE WHAT PRISON IS GOING TO
COME DOWN. IN ORDER TO SAVE
MONEY BECAUSE AS LONG AS THAT
EXIST IT'S GOING TO COST AS ANY
TO MAINTAIN IT. AND WE INVEST A
LOT OF MONEY INTO REPAIRS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
YEAR ROUND. OF THAT BECOMES OF
THE PUBLIC OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE.
OUTRAGED AT THE FACT WE WOULD
DO THAT SO IT'S NOT THAT WE'RE
NOT AWARE OF ALL THESE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE WITH TRYING TO
GRAPPLE WITH THE EASE. OF AS WE.
LOOK AT THE- PLACE TO
DECLINING. OF GOLD. TRY TO WE
TRIED TO MAN IS THE POPULATION
THAT YOU KNOW MANAGE THE
PRISONS THAT ARE THERE AND I
THINK OF MISTER KING INDICATED
EARLIER IN ONE OF THE REVIEWS
AND WE'VE SEEN THAT THE PRICE
KEEPS ONE UP BECAUSE NOW WE'VE
GOT THE SAME OUTLET THAT THE
SAME BUT THE ISSUE THAT THAT
WOULD PUTTING OUT WITH A FEW
PEOPLE SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT
WE SPENDING MORE MONEY PRISONER
OF RIGHT NOW THAN WE WERE WHEN
WE HAD A SMALL POPULATION. SOME
OF IT IS BECAUSE OF DESTRUCTION
WOULD HAVE SOME OF THIS BECAUSE
WOULD DO MORE PROGRAMMING BUT
BUT THE REAL SAVINGS WILL COME
HOPEFULLY AT SOME POINT START
SHUTTING DOWN EXPRESSIONS THEN
I THINK IT BECOMES IT MAKES
SENSE TO DO THE REPAIRS WE HAVE
TO DO BUT TO. YOU KNOW. WHAT
WAS HOME OF A- MILITARY BASE
HERE. AND IT IS BUILD A NEW
HOSPITAL NEW A PERFORMING ARTS
CENTER. AND A COUPLE OF THE NEW
THINGS. AND IN THE FIFTH SET IT
DOWN. SO WE HAD. TO FORMING
ARTS AND IS A NOBODY EVER
PERFORMED IN. THAT HOSPITAL
NEVER HAD A BIT IN IT THAT
ANYBODY EVER LAID AND- AND YET
THEY SAID SO THE DOWN BECAUSE
THEY DECIDED TO PUT. THEM CRD
THAT SHOULD DOWN I THINK IT WAS
AND SO AS A RESULT. WHEN WE
WITH THIS GREAT FACILITIES IF
IT JUST BILL. AND I AND I KNOW
SOMETIMES I CAN'T BE HELD
BECAUSE HOW LONG TO GET FROM
THE BILL. BUT OUR CONCERN
CONTINUES TO BE THAT. OF WE
KNOW THE REHABILITATION SAM
TRYING NEW THINGS WE HAVE TO
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE. BUT IF WE
WANT TO CLOSE A PRISON DO WE
WANT TO RENOVATE IT FOR. OKAY
AND I DON'T THINK WE WANT TO DO
THAT SO. THAT'S OUR CHALLENGE
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO RESPOND
TO BUT THAT'S OUR CHALLENGE IN
TERMS OF. HOW WE'RE GOING TO
MANAGE THE NUMBER PRISONS AND
THE OTHER THING THAT. ALL RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU FOR THIS PANEL
WE HAVE PANEL NUMBER TWO COMING
UP. IT DOES YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
NUMBER ONE HOLD WEALTHY HOLD
THEM. WE HAVE OUR STREETS
STRATEGIES FOR POPULATION
MANAGEMENT. WE HAVE MATTHEW
KATE THE TASHA. MINSKER AND
CAITLIN O'NEILL. ON THIS PANEL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITH THE
SPECTER. WHEN OF CORRECTIONS
YEAH. YEAH. THE SERVER HERE
YEAH OKAY. YEAH YEAH YEAH.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME TO THIS
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
FOLLOW ONCE AGAIN IN THE ORDER
THAT YOUR IN TO TALK WITH
STRATEGIES FOR POPULATION
MANAGEMENT. OF WELL I THINK WE
HAD. THE CORRECTIONS GOING FOR.
FOLLOWED BY THE LA FOLLOWED BY
THE SECRETARY OF C. C. R. AND
FOLLOWED BY THE ARMY YEAH.
FORMER ALIGHTED IN YOUR INTRO
MA'AM. WE COME ALONG WITH A
HEART PATIENT AND HAS
DRASTICALLY DECREASED OVER THE
YEARS THAT ARE ALL TIME HIGH OF
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND NOW WERE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND TWENTY
FOUR TO BE PRECISE AS OF
MIDNIGHT LAST NIGHT THAT DINGS
EVERY MIDNIGHT FOR ME AND-
UNFORTUNATELY. I'M STILL AWAKE
MORE TIMES I HEAR. HAS A
POPULATION. MY SPONSOR. SORRY
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS
HAVE REALLY SUBSTANTIALLY
CHANGE. CAITLYN IN HELL WITH
HERS SO IN TWO THOUSAND AN
ELEVEN. REALIGNMENT HAPPENED
AND THAT STOPPED THE INFLUX OF
NON SERIOUS NONVIOLENT
OFFENDERS INTO OUR SYSTEM. THAT
MADE A DRASTIC DIFFERENCE IN
OUR POPULATION. FOLLOWED BUT
PROPOSITION THIRTY SIX
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN
PROPOSITION THIRTY SIX WAS THE
THIRD STRIKERS MONSTERS
NONVIOLENT THIRD STRIKERS ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED OF THOSE
WITH TWENTY SIX HUNDRED OF
THOSE HAVE ALREADY BEEN
RELEASED STILL HAVE A FEW
REMAINING PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN STOP THE WHAT WE CALL THE
WATER OFFENSES THERE WAS A
MISDEMEANOR OR FELONY. AND NOT
DEPEND UPON. THE WALL WHO ARE
PART OF THAT AWAY AND MADE
MINIMAL MISDEMEANOR SO THAT
REALLY DRASTICALLY. REDUCED
WHAT WAS COMING IN THE FRONT
FRONT DOOR FOR MINOR PETTY
THEFT CRIMES OR- APPLE DRUG
POSSESSION. FOLLOWED BY
OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS THAT WE HAVE IS
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN.
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN WAS
VOTED BY THE VOTERS THAT SAID
OKAY WE DON'T WANT TO BE IN A
TIME WHERE POPULATION IS SO
HIGH LET'S DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT IS A FULL REFORM NO
BUT WHAT IT IS IT GIVES IT
OFFENDERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK OFF TIME OFF THEIR
SENTENCE. SO INDIVIDUALS GOING
TO MAKE A DECISION PROGRAM AND
GET CREDITS REDUCE REALLY
SUBSTANTIAL CREDIT SO FOR A GED
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA COLLEGE YOU
CAN GET A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DAYS. YOU CAN GET TWELVE WEEKS
OFF A YEAR. THAT'S REALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND WE'VE SEEN A
DRASTIC DECREASE IN OUR IN OUR
POPULATION BECAUSE OF IT. IN
ADDITION TO FIFTY SEVEN AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER OF BUILT WHAT
WE CALL THE ELEVEN SEVENTY DO
YOU RECALL OF SENTENCE THAT IS
REALLY BAD AND SIGNIFICANT FOR
US AND WE'VE HAD PRETTY GOOD
RESPONSE FROM THE COUNTIES SO
WE'RE ABLE TO SEND OFFENDERS
BACK FOR RESET AND SEEN THANKS
TO SOME LAW CHANGES THAT. OF
GOVERNOR BROWN'S ADMINISTRATION
AS IT RELATES TO ENHANCEMENTS
SO YOU CAN HAVE A CORE OFFENSE
OF LET'S SAY IT'S FOR FOUR
YEARS. YOU CAN HAVE AN EXPENSE
OF TEN. AND SO WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SEND OFFENDERS BACK
BASED ON GOOD CONDUCT. BACK TO
THE COURTS FOR RE SENTENCING
AND LIKE I SAID WE'VE SEEN SOME
PRETTY GOOD SUCCESS WITH THAT.
AND IS IT IS YOU GUYS KNOW THE
LIFE FOR POPULATION HAS REDUCED.
PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY WE'VE HAD
OVER FIVE THOUSAND LIFERS
RECEIVE DATES. OVER THE LAST
YOU KNOW EIGHT NINE YEARS A
TREND THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
BEFORE AND SO THAT'S REALLY
SIGNIFICANT WHAT THAT DOES IS
THE FOR THE POPULATION HOPE.
THAT YES I CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE CAN GET I CAN GET
OUT AND BE SUCCESSFUL. AS WELL
AS YOU KNOW I'M SURE YOU GUYS
HAVE HEARD ABOUT COMMUTATIONS
THE GOVERNOR HAS ABILITY. TO DO
COMMUTATIONS. EVEN LIFE WITHOUT
AND SO SEE IN THOSE CHANGES AND
HAVING PEOPLE BE ABLE TO. GET
RELEASE TO GET A SECOND CHANCE
HE'S REALLY MADE A DIFFERENCE
TO KEEP OUR INSTITUTIONS SAY.
I'M TRYING TO THE HANDOUT THAT
I WAS SPEAKING FROM EARLIER
CALLED PLANNING FOR THE
CLEANING IN MY PROPOSITION I'M
I'M GOING TO START ON PAGE
FOUR. AND ONE AND DISCUSS
ACTION BUT THE STATE COULD TAKE
IF IT WANTED TO ACCELERATE THE
ELIMINATION OF CONTRACTS AND OR
PRISON CLOSURE BEYOND WHAT
WOULD BE ALLOW WHAT WHAT WOULD
BE DOABLE JUST. AS THE
POPULATION DECLINES NATURALLY.
SERVICE THOSE OPTIONS FALL INTO
THREE CATEGORIES. THE FIRST
WOULD BE TWO AND WILL BE A SET
OF ACTIONS THAT OPTIONS THAT
WOULD RESULT IN A REDUCTION IN
THE OVERALL INMATE POPULATION.
AND FOR EXAMPLE ADD TO IT THAT
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS COULD
INITIATE RELEASE CONSIDERATION
FOR NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS SIXTY
DAYS EARLIER THAN THEY DO NOW
WHICH WOULD EXPEDITE RELEASES
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE'VE
PREVIOUSLY RECOMMENDED. AT THE
STATE COULD EXPAND ACCESS TO
MINIMUM CUSTODY PLACEMENTS
ALLOWING SOME INMATES TO EARN
MORE CREDITS. WE HAVE ALSO
PREVIOUSLY RECOMMENDED THIS. IN
ADDITION THE STATE COULD ENACT
SENTENCING CHANGES ISN'T
ENCOMPASSES A WIDE VARIETY OF
POSSIBILITIES FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE COULD EXPAND ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE ELDERLY OR YOUTH
OFFENDER PAROLE PROCESS SEAT.
AND THEN I WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE
THAT THERE'S ANOTHER A WITH A
WIDE VARIETY OF OPTIONS AS FAR
AS AND IT'S EASY ARE CAN PURSUE
TO USING ITS AUTHORITY TO
INCREASE IN MAKE CREDITS AS
WELL AS RECOMMENDING INMATES TO
THE COURTS FOR RE SENTENCING
UNDER THAT ELEVEN SEVENTY D.
PROCESS. THE THIRD EXCUSE ME
THE SECOND CATEGORY OF OPTIONS
WAY TO YES THE ACTIONS THAT
WOULD INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
INMATES IN PLACEMENTS. THAT ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE THIRTY FOUR
PRISONS THAT ARE SUBJECT TO THE
COURT ORDERED POPULATION CAP.
SUCH AS CONSERVATION CAMPS SO
FOR EXAMPLE AND THE STATE COULD
INCREASE THE CAN'T CONSERVATION
CAMP POPULATION BY EXPANDING IN
MADE ELIGIBILITY FOR CAMPS OR
INCREASING INCENTIVES FOR
INMATES TO CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN CAMPS. THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'VE PREVIOUSLY
RECOMMENDED. IN ADDITION THE
STATE COULD ALLOW MORE INMATES
TO SERVE THE LAST PORTION OF
THEIR SENTENCE IN THE
ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY PROGRAM.
AND THEN TURNING THE PAGE TO
PAGE FIVE. THE THIRD A CATEGORY
OF OPTIONS WOULD BE TO
ESSENTIALLY OPERATE THE THIRTY
FOUR PRISONS WITH A SMALLER
BUFFER WHICH IS SOMETHING I
MENTIONED ON PANEL ONE AND- AT
THAT THE STATE IS ALLOWED TO
HOUSE UP TO A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND INMATES IN
ITS- THIRTY FOUR PRESENCE. BUT
CHOOSES THE HOUSE ABOUT ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND JUST
TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF BUFFER
IN CASE THERE'S AN UNEXPECTED
INCREASE. SO THIS OPTION WOULD
JUST INVOLVE HOUSING HERE IN ME
AN EXCUSE ME HOUSING MORE
INMATES IN STATE OWNED AND
OPERATED PRISONS AND THEREFORE
OPERATING A SMALLER BUFFER. AND
THE STATE CHOSE THIS OPTION IT
MAY WANT TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
ACTIONS TO MITIGATE THE
INCREASED RISK OF VIOLATING A
COURT ORDER. YES SOME OF NEXT
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MATT
KATE I WAS THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL OF THE PRISON SYSTEM
FROM 200-042-2000 EIGHT AND THE
SECRETARY FROM TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TO THE END OF. TWENTY
TWELVE. I'M CURRENTLY IN
PRIVATE SECTOR. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WE BUILT THE WRONG
PRISONS BUT EVERYONE DID RIGHT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. I AM
VERY EXPENSIVE TO BUILD A TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION PLUS
VERY EXPENSIVE TO MAINTAIN AS
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD. I'M AN
EXCELLENT DESIGN FOR PREVENTING
ESCAPES A VERY POOR DESIGN FOR.
OUR PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS. THE SITE THE SOUND
THE SMILE THE TEMPERATURE ALL
POORLY DESIGNED FOR PROVIDING A
THERAPEUTIC MILIEU. AND SO WHAT
DO YOU DO THEY'RE TOO EXPENSIVE
TO TEAR DOWN AND TOO EXPENSIVE
TO REBUILD. THE ANSWER FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS REDUCING
POPULATION THROUGH REDUCING
RECIDIVISM. 300-003-8000
INMATES ARE RELEASED EVERY YEAR
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES IF YOU CAN
REDUCE RECIDIVISM BY 10% THAT'S
ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND INMATES A
YEAR. RIGHT AND THAT NUMBER
DECLINES EACH YEAR AND SO ON.
HOW DO YOU DO THAT I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE LEGISLATURE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS ON THE
RIGHT TRACK. CURRENT THERE'S
CURRENTLY AN INVITATION FOR BED
OUT THAT IS GOING TO EXPAND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS IN THE
PRISONS IMPROVE THEM AS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM THE WEBSITE AND ALSO
OFFICE I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT. FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THE SECRET SAUCE IS TO COMBINE
THOSE IN PRISON PROGRAMS WITH
EFFECTIVE AFTER CARE AND
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT. SINCE
LEAVING THE DEPARTMENT I JOIN
THE BOARD OF THE ENTIRE CITIZEN
COALITION AND LOS ANGELES ALSO.
HAVE TAKEN ON AS CLIENTS A
COUPLE OF NONPROFIT PROVIDERS
WHO ARE PART OF THE MEN'S
COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAM AND
ALSO THAT THE FEMALE VERSION
CALLED THE CZ TRP. FOR MY
PERSPECTIVE RIGHT NOW THERE'S
ABOUT A THOUSAND OF THOSE BEDS
IN THOSE BEDS FOR EXAMPLE FOR
THE MEN AND THEY CAN BE
RELEASED UP TO FOURTEEN MONTHS.
BEFORE THE END OF THEIR
SENTENCE. TO THEIR INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES IN THOSE PROGRAMS
THEY CAN RECEIVE. NOT ONLY RYAN
EDUCATION BUT TRUE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES SOMETHING THE
DEPARTMENT CAN'T REALLY PROVIDE
BECAUSE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
CHALLENGES. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO GET THE RIGHT IN MADE IN THE
RIGHT PROGRAM AT THE RIGHT TIME
IN THE STATE THIS BIG. BUT IN A
COMMUNITY RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM
FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S ONE IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOHN STORAGE
DISTRICT THAT'S REALLY
EXCELLENT THEY DO A VERY NICE
JOB. BUT WHEN THOSE INMATES
COMPLETE THEIR PROGRAMS THEY
HAVE JOBS THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT
OF HOUSING THAT WRAP AROUND
SERVICES. I TO ADDRESS THERE
ARE. ANY OUR CRIMINAL GENIC
NEEDS THAT THEY MAY STILL HAVE
IN THE EARLY INDICATIONS ARE
YOU'LL GET THE KIND OF OUR
RECIDIVISM REDUCTIONS THAT THAT
THE STATE NEEDS. SO WHAT ARE
THE RISKS IN MY PURSE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THE REST OF LARGELY
POLITICAL. I THESE INMATES
SHOULD THEY WALK AWAY FROM
THESE FACILITIES AND COMMIT A
CRIME THAT'S A POLITICAL
PROBLEM FOR THE GOVERNOR. FOR
THE DEPARTMENT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT THE TRUTH IS
THESE INMATES WERE GOING TO BE
RELEASED ANYWAY. AND SO RELEASE
IN THEM AND A MATTER OF MONTHS
EARLIER THAN THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN RELEASED IN
A SETTING WHERE THEY HAVE THE
BEST CHANCE TO SUCCEED.
ACTUALLY IN FROM WILL REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF VICTIMS IN
CALIFORNIA MAKE IT A SAFER
PLACE TO LIVE. WILL HELP THOSE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS RE ENTER
SUCCESSFUL WEIGHT I DON'T
THAT'S NOT ONLY AN ISSUE FOR
THAT INDIVIDUAL HUMAN BEING BUT
ALSO FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND HAS A
RIPPLE EFFECT I THINK ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S WHERE I
WOULD INVEST MY MIND MY MONEY
AND MY TIME IF I WERE IN YOUR
CHAIRS. RIGHT NOW THERE'S ONLY
A THOUSAND FIFTY OF THOSE BEDS
I THINK THE STATE SHOULD
INCREASE THOSE NUMBERS OVER
TIME AGAIN I REPRESENT SOME OF
THE NONPROFIT TO DO THIS WORK
IN ALL CANDOR BUT- I DO THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THEY'RE DOING
THE RIGHT THING. FOR THE RIGHT
REASONS THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NATASHA
MINSKER I'M AN ATTORNEY AND
CONSULTANT AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ISSUES FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS. MY
TOPIC IS FRONT AND SOLUTIONS TO
REDUCING THE PRISON POPULATION.
AND I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON TWO
APPROACHES. ONE GIVE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO DO THEIR JOBS WELL. AN
TO SENTENCING REFORM. YEAH WHAT
A LOT OF ATTENTION HAS BEEN
PLACATE TO THE ROLE OF JUDGES
AND PROSECUTORS IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM VERY LITTLE
ATTENTION IS PAID TO THE ROLE
OF THE PUBLIC DEFENDER. IT IS
THE JOB OF THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
TO KEEP THEIR CLIENT OUT OF
PRISON. LET'S GIVE THEM THE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT JOB WELL.
IF PUBLIC DEFENDERS HAD MORE
RESOURCES THEY WOULD DO A
BETTER JOB OF PROTECTING
INNOCENT PEOPLE FROM WRONGFUL
CONVICTION. AND THEY WOULD DO A
BETTER JOB CONFRONTING THE
ROUTINE OVER CHARGING BY
PROSECUTORS THAT LEADS TO
UNFAIR AND UNNECESSARILY LONG
SENTENCES. PUBLIC DEFENDERS ARE
ALSO IN DAILY CONTACT WITH THE
NEEDIEST PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. SONICALLY HOMELESS
PEOPLE WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS IN PEOPLE WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES. I CAN'T
TELL YOU THE NUMBER OF TIMES
THAT AS A PUBLIC DEFENDER I
SAID TO A JUDGE. MY CLIENT
NEEDS A PROGRAM. AND I WAS MET
WITH THE RETORT. WE HAVE A
PROGRAM FOR YOUR CLIENT IT'S
CALLED STATE PRISON. WHAT A
NUMBER OF TIMES I QUOTE
SUCCEEDED I GETTING MY CLIENT
OUT OF JAIL AND WONDERED WHY
SINCE HE WOULD BE SLEEPING ON
THE STREETS THAT NIGHT. IMAGINE
A WORLD IN WHICH PUBLIC
DEFENDERS HAD SOCIAL WORKERS
AND NAVIGATORS TO HELP THEIR
CLIENTS FIND STABLE HOUSING AND
TREATMENT. WORLD IN WHICH FROM
THE FIRST ENCOUNTER PUBLIC
DEFENDER COULD SAY HOW CAN I
HELP WHAT DO YOU NEED HOW DO WE
KEEP YOU OUT OF PRISON FOREVER.
WE HAVE AN ARMY OF ADVOCATES
WORKING TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
PRISON AND HELP THE NEEDIEST
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. LET'S
GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES TO DO
THAT JOB WELL. I WANT TO
ADDRESS IN SENTENCING REFORM.
IF THE ROLE OF JUDGES TO DECIDE
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE AND FAIR
SENSES IN AN INDIVIDUAL CASE
AND IF THE ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO SET THE
PARAMETERS FOR JUDGES TO ENSURE
FAIR AND JUST SENSE IS AN
INDIVIDUAL CASES AND TO SERVE
THE INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIANS
AS A WHOLE. OUR SENTENCING LAWS
FAILED TO ACHIEVE THOSE BASIC
GOALS. I'M GONNA SUGGEST FIVE
SPECIFIC SENSING REFORMS THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CONSIDER. ONE I
WOMEN EIGHT THE REMAINING
RESTRICTIONS THAT PREVENT
JUDGES FROM CHOOSING A SENTENCE
OTHER THAN PRISON. GIVE JUDGES
FULL DISCRETION TO CHOOSE
PROBATION OR CHOOSE A PROGRAM
WHERE TO STRIKE AN ENHANCEMENT
SO THAT PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO GO
TO PRISON. TO ADDRESS THE
CONTINUING LEGACY OF THE WAR ON
DRUGS IN OUR SENTENCING LAWS.
THAT SENDS THE LOWEST POSSIBLE
SENDS FOR SALE OF COCAINE
INCLUDING CRACK. IS THREE YEARS
STATE PRISON. THE LOWEST
POSSIBLE SENDS FOR SALE OF
HEROIN IS SIXTEEN MONTHS. THAT
SPECIFIC DISPARITY ADDRESSING
BACK TO SEVERITY WOULD HAVE THE
BIGGEST IMPACT ON OUR JAIL
POPULATIONS IT IS A STARK
EXAMPLE OF THE WAYS IN WHICH
THE WAR ON DRUGS CONTINUES TO
IMPACT OUR SENTENCING LAWS AND
UNFAIR WAY. THREE THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD RE EVALUATE
SENTENCES. FOR THE OFFENSES
THAT LEAD TO THE LARGEST NUMBER
OF PRISON COMMITMENTS WHICH ARE
SALT AND ROBBERY. IF WE WERE TO
REDUCE THE LOWEST POSSIBLE
SENSE FROM SIXTEEN MONTHS TO
TWELVE MONTHS OR EVEN FOURTEEN
MONTHS. JUST A COUPLE OF MONTHS
LESS ABOUT WHAT WAS SENDS.
BECAUSE IT IMPACTS A LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IT WOULD HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
POPULATION WITH HAVING NO
IMPACT ON PUBLIC SAFETY. FOUR
WE NEED TO BRING BACK THE
COMMONSENSE RULES WE USED TO
HAVE THAT LIMITED STACKING
ENHANCEMENTS AND SENSES ONE ON
TOP OF THE. WE USE RULES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT SAID YOU CAN'T
HAVE AN ENHANCEMENT FOR USE OF
A WEAPON AND THEN I ALSO HAVE
AN ENHANCEMENT FOR THE INJURY
THAT THAT WEAPON BECAUSE- AND
HAVE ANOTHER ENHANCEMENT ON ON
TOP OF THAT. WE USED TO HAVE
RULES THAT SAID THE STANDS FOR
YOUR OFFENSE. NEEDS TO BE THE
LARGEST PART YOUR SENTENCE AND
ENHANCEMENTS NEED TO BE JUST A
TINY PORTION ADDED ON. WE GOT
RID OF THOSE RULES. AND THEN
EXTREME SENSING BECAME THE NORM
IN CALIFORNIA AND OUR PRISON
POPULATION EXPLODED WE NEED TO
BRING BACK THOSE COMMONSENSE
RULES THEY WORKED ONCE THEY
WILL WORK AGAIN. THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD DO MORE TO
ADDRESS BY CARRIER LIABILITY
THAT'S WHEN ONE. IS PUNISHED
FOR THE BEHAVIOR OF ANOTHER
PERSON. YOU DID A GREAT JOB
MADE A GREAT START WITH THE
FELONY MURDER RULE BUT WE HAVE
MORE ENHANCEMENTS AND MORE
OFFENSES THAT PUNISH ONE PERSON
FOR SOMEONE ELSE'S BEHAVIOR FOR
EXAMPLE THE GUN ENHANCEMENT. WE
CAN ADD TEN OR TWENTY YEARS ON
A PERSON'S SENTENCE WHEN THEY
DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A GUN. WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT IN CALIFORNIA
YOU ARE ONLY SENDS AND HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR YOUR OWN
BEHAVIOR. FINALLY THIS IS
OUTSIDE OF THE REALM OF THE
LEGISLATURE BUT ANY
CONVERSATION ABOUT REDUCING THE
PRISON POPULATION HAS TO
INCLUDE MENTION OF THE THREE
STRIKES LAW. THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT REFORM TO REDUCING
OUR PRISON POPULATION AND
ENDING EXTREME SENSING IT'S TO
REPEAL THE THREE STRIKES LAW.
THANK YOU I LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING THESE IDEAS WITH YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK EVERYONE IS SPOKEN RIGHT
OKAY WONDERFUL OF THE ANY OF
THE MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. YEAH. MINE WORKS HERE.
SO. MAYBE IT IS ANYONE CAN IT
GET ENOUGH. WE TRY TO ADDRESS
THIS PART OF WHAT EACH OF YOUR
ST IS A PARADIGM SHIFT IN THE
WAY WE DEAL WITH GROW JUSTICE
IN GENERAL I JUST GOT BACK FROM
NORWAY. IN NORWAY. THEY BELIEVE
THAT THE SENTENCE THE JUDGE
GIVE YOU IS YOUR PUNISHMENT.
PLUS THEY WILL ALSO SAY YOU
CAN'T SERVE MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS WHICH MEANS. WHEN YOU GO
TO PRISON IT'S ABOUT
REHABILITATION. BECAUSE YOU'RE
COMING OUT WHAT YOU KILL ONE
PERSON OR TWO HUNDRED ONE
PEOPLE THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE
YOU MIGHT COME OUT AGAINST
WOMEN TO REHABILITATE IF YOU
STILL WANNA GRAIN OF CORN OR OR
BUSH A GREATER QUIRK YOU'RE
COMING OUT SO WE NEED TO
REBUILD SO THEY HAVE A LOT OF
PROGRAMS THERE. THAT THAT THAT.
WHAT PART OF IN THIS IS THE
POLITICAL THING. THE REASON
THAT STARTED. THIS WHOLE
PARADIGM SHIFT. IS NUMBER TWO
DURING THE **** OCCUPATION. OF
THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS WERE IN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS. AND WHEN
THEY GET OUT THEY CAN BEGIN TO
PRIME MINISTER ANY RAN THE
COUNTRY. IN THEIR MIND THEY
HAVE A SAYING IF YOU WANT
REFORM TO PRISON SYSTEM YOU
NEED SEND EVERY POLITICIAN TO
PRESENT. ARE YOU VOLUNTEERING.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS FUNNY BUT
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN PRISON AND
ALL THE ATROCITIES THAT THE
NAZI'S INFLICTED ON THEM IN
MIND THEY DIDN'T WANT TO TRY TO
CHANGE THE PUBLIC'S. VERSION OF
VISION OF WHAT. THE ABILITY
ASIAN SHOULD BE ENRICHED EXCEPT
IT WAS DIFFICULT BUT THEY HAD A
AN INFRASTRUCTURE OF
POLITICIANS WHO WERE. PRESENT
AND WOOD. THE CHANGES IN OUR
PRIME MINISTER TIME DID THAT
AND SO THIS IS A HUGE LEFT IS
NOT AS EASY AS AS AS WE WOULD
THINK AND SO I. TO JOIN WITH US
TO TRY TO CHANGE MINDS IF
ANYONE THOUGHT ABOUT. YOU KNOW
IT YET THESE ARE GREAT PROGRAMS
ARE GREAT BUT IF YOU EVER
THOUGHT ABOUT HOW DO WE PUT
TOGETHER THAT THIS THIS WHOLE
NEW SYSTEM BUT ALSO TO CONVINCE
THE PUBLIC. THAT THIS IS GOOD
NOT LEAVE IT WOULD JUST ONE
EXAMPLE I WAS ABLE TO GET A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
REHABILITATION EARLY ON IN MY
CAREER IN TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY
THIRTEEN BECAUSE I WAS ABLE TO
CONVINCE REPUBLICANS AND PEOPLE
WHO ARE. THREE STRIKES LAW IN
ORDER TO SAY. IT COSTS TOO MUCH
TO SEND PEOPLE TO PRISON. I CAN
SAVE YOU EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR IF YOU GIVE ME A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
GIVE YOU A BILLION DOLLARS BACK
SO THEY GAVE ME A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO DO
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS. AND
YOU COULD SELL THAT TO THE
PUBLIC AND THEY COULD THEY
COULD GRASP IN JUNE AT AND SO I
HAVE. THOUGHT ABOUT HOW TO TOOK
TO MAKE THIS MORE PALATABLE TO
THOSE WHO MAY NOT BE AS
OBVIOUSLY RECEPTIVE IS THIS
AUDIENCE TO TRY THESE IDEAS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST US IN
THIS ROOM WE'VE GOT TO CONVINCE
SOME PEOPLE OUTSIDE THIS ROOM.
WHO DON'T WHO MAY NOT BE AS IN
LIKE. AS WE ARE. AND
EVERYBODY'S LOOKING IMAGE TO
KATE NOW. I'LL SHOW THAT I
THINK ONE THE PUBLIC IS MORE ON
OUR SIDE THAN WE KNOW IN IN IN
EVERY CALL EVERY SURVEY OF THE
PUBLIC SHOWS THAT PEOPLE WANT
FUNDING FOCUSED ON. COMMUNITIES
SCHOOLS AND INVESTING IN HEALTH
CARE AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IT'S ON US TO MAKE SURE THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTAND UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT WHEN WE FOR EXAMPLE
GIVE SOCIAL WORKERS TO PUBLIC
DEFENDERS TO HELP THEIR CLIENTS
FIND HOUSING AND TREATMENT.
THAT IS ABOUT ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND IT'S ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE GET
PROPER HEALTH CARE AND THAT
WHEN WE ARE INVESTING IN
EDUCATION THAT INCLUDES
EDUCATION THAT KEEPS PEOPLE OUT
OF PRISON AND HELPS PEOPLE
IMPRISONED. SUCCEED WHEN THEY
COME OUT SO I THINK IT'S THE
SUPPORT FOR SHIFTING AMONG THE
PUBLIC OF SHIFTING FUNDING TO
EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE
INVESTING IN COMMUNITIES IS
THERE AND WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF EXPLAINING THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING. WOULD
YOU SAY. NUMBER I WAS GONNA SAY
REHABILITATION DOES EQUATE TO
PUBLIC SAFETY NEW GIVE SOMEBODY
A SKILL THEY DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE
AND THE ACTUAL CHANCE TO
SUCCEED AS MATT TALKED ABOUT
OUR COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAMS.
THEREFORE NOT TO GET A JOB
RIGHT TO HELP WAS TO HAVE THIS
KIND OF A SOFT LANDING PLACE
WHILE THE FIGURE OUT THEIR NEXT
STEP SAVE A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY
WHEN YOU CAN PRO ROLE WITH TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN IN YOUR
POCKET TO WHERE YOU CAN BUY A
CAR. RENDON APARTMENT YOU HAVE
A GREATER CHANCE OF SUCCESS.
OUR PART OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T TWO
SENTENCES. BUT WE HAVE A GREAT
SENSE REFORM AS AN AGENCY AND
I'VE BEEN WITH THIS AGENCY
LONGER THAN I HEAR TALK ABOUT
ABOUT THIRTY TWO PLUS YEARS AND
I BELIEVE IN THE EVOLUTION THAT
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THAT IT'S
TIME. YOU DON'T HAVE IN OUR
POPULATION I REMEMBER OUR
POPULATION HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND IT WAS NOT FUN WORKING
INSIDE THE INSTITUTIONS AT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND. FOR ANYBODY. AND SO
SEEN THAT THAT SHIFT AND SO WE
HAVE A ROLE IN THAT. AND TO
PREPARE EVERYONE FOR RELEASE
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE A ROLE
AND I YOU KNOW I SHARE WITH
GUYS AND GET IT A CHANCE OF A
LIFETIME WHETHER THEY WERE.
HUNDRED EIGHTY YEARS TO LIFE
AND THEY GOT. A RECALL OF
SATINS WHAT A GIFT THAT WAS YOU
HAVE TO BE AN AMBASSADOR OF
THAT. AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL SO THAT.
PEOPLE WILL SOFTEN UP TO
FURTHER REFORMS AS THEY COME
DOWN. I GUESS THE RUNNING I
WOULD ADD TO THAT IS THAT PART
OF THE PROBLEM WITH OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM IS THAT IF YOU'RE
CONVICTED IN LOS ANGELES DURING
THE BAY AREA YOU'RE NOT SENT
TO. A LOS ANGELES OR BAY AREA
FACILITY YOU YOU'RE LIKELY TO
BE SENT TO WASCO OR IT CENTRAL
VALLEY OR- TO LASSEN COUNTY OR
TO PELICAN BAY. AND I THINK TO
WIN THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
PEOPLE YOU HAVE TO OFFENDERS
HAVE TO BE CONNECTED TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND SO THAT MEANS
TAKING. TRYING TO KEEP MORE
OFFENDERS LOCAL. AND THEN WHEN
THEY NEVER LEAVE OUR COMMUNITY
BEGIN WITH. OR IT MEANS
RETURNING THEM BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
SO THAT THEY CAN BE. SUPPORTED
BY THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS BY
THEIR FRIENDS BY THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT THAT'S
WHERE THE HEARTS AND MINDS ARE
AND SO AGAIN. WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH RE ENTRY WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH DISH NO PROBATION
SERVICES KEEPING. CRIMINAL
JUSTICE LOCAL IS THE KEY TO THE
HEARTS AND MINDS ARGUMENT I
THINK. JUST VERY QUICKLY TO
SECRETARY QUE KIND OF WHAT YOU
ADVOCATED FOR IS THIS EXPANSION
OF THE MAIL COMMUNITY REENTRY
PROGRAM IN THE CUSTODY TO
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONAL YET YOU
PROGRAM. ONE OF MY QUESTIONS IS
HOW DO YOU SCALE THAT YOU HAD A
TIME WHERE WE ARE HAVING
DIFFICULTY BUILDING HOUSING
EXPANDING THAT FOOTPRINT HOW
HOW COULD WE ACTUALLY SCALE IT
TO GET TO THE KINDS OF NUMBERS
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE IT
MORE EFFECTIVE. THAN THE TENS
OF THOUSANDS. WELL I THINK IS
DO IT AND SO THERE'S NO REASON
WE CAN'T GO FROM A THOUSAND TO
TWO THOUSAND. RIGHT THAT'S JUST
ONE LITTLE STEP. AND THEN IF
YOU PUT THAT BUT THAT OUT TO
BID YOU LET THOSE THOSE
NONPROFITS AND OTHERS CAN AND
COMPETE. AND YOU GO COMMUNITY
BY COMMUNITY AND YOU JUST DO
YOUR BEST A LITTLE AT A TIME
THE PRISON SYSTEM DIDN'T YOU
KNOW GROW TO WHERE IT IS
OVERNIGHT EITHER. AND SO THE
SOLUTION SHOULDN'T BE SEEN AS A
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO HAPPEN I
MEAN WE GO FROM A THOUSAND TO
TWO THOUSAND HAVE A FIVE YEAR
PLAN. TO CLOSE ONE PRISON.
RIGHT THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING I
THINK YOU CAN ALL BE PROUD OF.
GOOD YOU HAD MENTIONED I THINK
YOU'RE DECLARE WHAT THE
POLITICAL RISK OF IF YOU HAD
JUST ONE PERSON. RE OFFEND THAT
HAPPEN TO BE IN THIS.
PARTICULAR PROGRAM SO HOW DO
YOU. HOW DO AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
SORT OF. TRY TO PREVENT THAT
GREAT THING ABOUT BEING A
LAWMAKERS THAT YOU CAN MAKE A
LAW. AND SO. IT IS ALSO IF
YOU'RE THE SECRETARY OF
CORRECTIONS YOU ALSO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE REGULATION. TO
THE GOVERNOR IN SO WHAT I WOULD
DO IS CONSIDER SOMETHING LIKE A
PROGRAM WHERE WE YOUR RELEASED
IT'S A CONDITIONAL RELEASE. AND
SO YOU'RE NOT AN ENEMY. STILL
IN ONE OF THESE NCRP PROGRAMS
YOU'RE NOW A POORLY OR YOUR
CONDITIONALLY RELEASED. FOR
EARLY AND SO IF YOU IF YOU MESS
UP YEAH YOU CAN GO BACK TO
PRISON AND HAVE TO SERVE THE
REMAINDER OF YOUR TIME. BUT
THERE'S WE CAN DO SOMETHING TO
NOT IDENTIFY THESE PEOPLE ANY
LONGER AS INMATES WE CAN CALL
THEM SOMETHING ELSE SO THAT IF
IT IF SOMEBODY HAS A FAMILY
EMERGENCY OR OR OBEYED JUST
MAKE ANOTHER MISTAKE RIGHT
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN RELAPSE IS
GONNA HAVE WE KNOW THAT
SCIENTIFICALLY IS TRUE. THESE
DON'T NEED TO BE ESCAPES RIGHT
THEY NEED TO THEY CAN BE PAROLE
VIOLATION AND THESE AND THESE.
HUMAN BEINGS CAN BE DEALT WITH
THROUGH AN APPROPRIATE SANCTION
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT BASED ON
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES THEY THEY
BY CALLING THEM INMATES AND BY
CALL ONLY TIMES EVERY TIME
SOMEBODY DOESN'T SHOW FOR
CURFEW TO SAY THERE'S BEEN IN
THE SKATE. IS RIDICULOUS IT'S
JUST TOO MUCH POLITICAL RISK
YOU DON'T NEED. TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU. THAT
EVEN IT SORT OF MY VERY
PROGRESSIVE DISTRICT OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE PEOPLE WHO SHOW
UP. ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT THE
PROPERTY CRIMES IN THE AUTO
BURGLARIES AND THEY NEVER SAY
WILL. YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT
THE NEVER THANK AND PROP 47-57
THEY'RE THEY'RE ASKING THEIR
COSTLY ASKING FOR ENHANCEMENT
NOW THEY ARE. THEY ARE THE
MINORITY HOW DO YOU CREATE THE-
PUBLIC ENVIRONMENT TECHNICAL
WORK WITH THE PUBLIC SENTIMENT
IS BECAUSE I DO AGREE THAT
THINK THAT. THE PUBLIC OVERALL
IS WHAT YOU DESCRIBE BUT
THEY'RE NOT THE FOLKS THAT SHOW
UP. TO ALL OF OUR MEETINGS ALL
OVER TOWN HOMES ARE NOT THE
ONES WHO ARE. BEING BEING
FRANKLY VOCAL OR PARTICIPATORY.
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT YOU
ARE USING ON. THE BACK. I THINK
IT'S REALLY. WHY THE TWO IDEAS
I TALK ABOUT THE BEST HAND IN
HAND WHY IT'S REALLY REALLY I
THINK IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS AMONG THE
COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
CYCLING THROUGH OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM ON A DAILY BASIS
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE HONEST AT
THAT IS A REALITY AND WE HAVE
TO BE CREATIVE ABOUT PROVIDING
THE RESOURCES TO HELP THOSE
PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW THE FOLKS
IN MY COMMUNITY I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND MY NEIGHBORS
COMPLAIN THE SAME WAY AND I
LOOK AT THEM AND SAY WHAT ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT WE LIVE IN A
GREAT NEIGHBORHOOD RIGHT THEY
SEE THEY CHOOSE TO FOCUS ON
WHAT. THAT'S THAT'S THEM AND
THEY ARE GIVEN MESSAGES VERY
INTENTIONALLY BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT THIS IS
BECAUSE OF PROP FORTY SEVEN
RIGHT THIS IS NOT AN ACCIDENTAL
ASSOCIATION THAT MY NEIGHBORS
HAVE COME UP WITH BY THEMSELVES
RIGHT THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL WHO CAME TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION SAID
YEAH THE PROBLEM IS PROP FORTY
SEVEN GAVE THEM ALL THE TALKING
POINTS. SO WE NEED TO RESPOND
TO THAT AND SAY. CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS OF PEOPLE HUMAN
BEINGS WHO DON'T HAVE A PLACE
TO SLEEP AND CYCLING IN AND OUT
OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS REAL. AND WE WANT TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION TO ADDRESS
THAT. AND I BELIEVE IT'S REALLY
ONE OF THE BEST AND LEAST USED
RESOURCES IF THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN THE
CONTACT THEIR MAKING EVERY DAY.
WITH THE PEOPLE WHO MOST NEED
HELP. BUT WE I THINK WE'VE
HEARD A LOT IN AND THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH FOR IT. JUST WANT
TO SAY AS AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MENTIONED PROBABLY THERE'S NOT
AN ISSUE THAT HASN'T BEEN
RAISED TODAY THAT. MANY OF US
HAVE NOT TRIED TO DO. AND SO I
WANT TO MAKE THAT THE PUBLIC NO
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT THAT THE
FOLKS AT THE PIER OF. DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT THESE ARE THE
THESE ARE THE WARRIORS WHO DO
IT. AND SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT'S CLEAR BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES WE DO AND WE'VE DONE
SOME THINGS RELATED TO IT. I
THINK YOU'VE SEEN MOST WERE
RECENTLY THE A WE'VE BEEN
LIMITED THE ENHANCEMENTS SOME
OF THE ENHANCEMENTS SO THAT WAS
IMPORTANT. TERMS OF REDUCING
THAT AS WELL AS CHANGING THE
THIS THE DEFINITION OF CRACK
COCAINE. OF SO THAT IT'S NOT
THE UP HEAVY HAVE BEEN THE
THING AS IT WAS BEFORE. IN THE
END AND BASICALLY TREATING IT
AS COCAINE. WHICH WOULD HAVE
BEEN HELPFUL WITH AN AWFUL LOT
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO BEEN
INCARCERATED. AND OUT AND WE'VE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR SENTENCING
REFORM. AND THAT'S A HARD THING
TO DO AND WE AND WHILE WE HAVE
ADVOCATES AND SUPPORTERS AT CDC
ARE SOME OF THEM. WE ALSO HAVE
TO DO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
POWERFUL LOBBY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I KNOW THAT
FROM THREE NINE TWO. THE
POWERFUL LOBBY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHICH ALSO SAYS
THEY DID NOT AS POWERFUL AS IT
USED TO BE. SO WE KNOW THAT WE
CAN BE DONE BUT IT REQUIRES A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
SUPPORT. FOR THIS TO HAPPEN AND
I THINK WE PASS LAWS THAT THAT
LET US KNOW PEOPLE. OF WANT TO
THINK ABOUT THAT IF YOU PUT IT
OUT THERE LIKE THAT BUT THEN
WHAT HAPPENS AS YOU POINT OUT.
THE FIRST TIME SOMETHING
HAPPENS PEOPLE BLAME IT ON BOTH
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW. AND AS A
RESULT WE FIND OURSELVES
BATTLING TO MAKE SURE THE
PROPERTY SEVEN PROP WITH. THIS
NUMBER THAT NUMBER BASICALLY
SURVIVE SO WE'VE GOT A
TREMENDOUS TASK HERE BUT I
THINK WE'RE WE'RE COMMITTED TO.
OF THE. ONE THING WE HAVE DONE
IN THE LEGISLATURE'S WE HAVE
COMMITTED OURSELVES. TO
REHABILITATION. WHEN I CHANGE
THE DEFINITION OF SENTENCING.
WE WANTED TO PUT. SOMETHING FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY AND
REHABILITATION. WE COULDN'T GET
AWAY WITH THOSE TWO WORDS WE
HAD PUT PUNISHMENT IN IT.
THERE'S PEOPLE LIKE PUNISHMENT.
EVEN THOSE BEING IN PRISON IS A
PUNISHMENT BY ITSELF. BUT WE
COULD NOT GET THAT BILL PASSED
WITHOUT PUNISHMENT THROWN IN
THE MIDDLE OF IT. SO WE DID
CHANGE IT FROM THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND REHABILITATION BUT
PUNISHMENT IS STILL THERE.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE MENTALITY.
OF FOLKS WITH REGARDS TO.
PUBLIC SAFETY. SO WE STILL
BATTLING THESE ISSUES A VERY
GOOD. DISCUSSION THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU OF SIN OF
SECRETARY KATE. WHAT YOU
RECOMMEND. THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. AND AS WE
BEGIN TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN.
CONTINUE TO REDUCE THE
POPULATION AND REDUCE.
RECIDIVISM AT THE SAME TIME
THIS OBVIOUSLY. BECOMES A MAJOR
PIECE OF IT SO THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH. THANK. OUR THIRD
POINT MENTAL AND WE WANT TO TRY
TO GET THIS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SIMPLY BECAUSE WE KNOW
WE HAVE A- SOME OF YOU WILL
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY WANT TO ASK. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU KEEP THEM TO QUESTIONS. AND
NOT DISSERTATIONS NOT LONG
STATE LET'S OF PEOPLE'S
FEELINGS AND- ALL THOSE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE REALLY HAD IF
THERE'S A QUESTION TO BE ASKED.
THINK ABOUT IT AS A QUESTION
NOT AS A STATEMENT. OKAY WE'LL
BE ABLE THAT THIRD PANEL WITH
HEARING FROM CDC ARE. AS WELL
AS SOMEONE FROM LA AND SOMEONE
FROM THE OFFICE OF THE OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH FOR COMING. WOULD
TAKE THEM IN THAT ORDER SO CVC
OURS FIRST. OF FOLLOWED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND. THEN FOLLOWED BY OFFICERS
BACK AGAIN THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY MY NAME'S RUNS
USE THAT I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS WITHIN
C. C. R. I THINK KEEPING WITH
YOUR PREVIOUS COMMENTS I'M
GONNA TRY AND KEEP IT BRIEF AND
NOT READ DIRECTLY FROM MY NOTES
BUT I WANT TO KIND OF BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE SOME OF THE RE ENTRY
EFFORTS THAT WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT CITY SEE OUR- REALLY.
RE ENTRY STARTS FORTY RPG AND
THE DIVISION AT RECEPTION IT
STARTS FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
ROBUST ORIENTATION PROCESS THE
DEPARTMENT STANDS BEHIND AND
THAT WE HAVE OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS INVOLVED
WITH RIGHT IN THE VERY
BEGINNING SO THAT'S WHERE IT
STARTS FOR US AND THEN WE FOCUS
SIMPLY ON MAKING SURE THE
PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT.
EDUCATIONAL FOCUSING ON
ACHIEVING A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
OR EQUIVALENT SEE GETTING
PEOPLE MOTIVATED TO COLLEGE AND
REALLY CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON
THOSE EDUCATIONAL FACTORS
SOMETIMES FACTORS THAT HAVE I
HAD DECADES OF FAILURES IN
ATTENDANCE AND HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE FOR THEM I'M SO REALLY
STARTING TO FOCUS ON THOSE
THINGS AND THEN. NOT BY
ACCIDENT CDC ARE CURRENTLY
FOCUSED A LOT OF ITS
PROGRAMMING NEAR THE END OF
INCARCERATIONS THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT INCLUDE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS THINGS
THAT ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS
SPECIFIC NEEDS LIKE SUBSTANCE
USE OR ANGER MANAGEMENT VICTIM
IMPACT AND THEN ALSO CAREER
TECHNICAL TRADES ARE
UNDERSECRETARY SPOKE A LOT
ABOUT. BUT REALLY CREATING
TRADES THAT ARE INNOVATIVE COST
EFFECTIVE AND ARE TRYING TO
GIVE PEOPLE A SKILL NOT JUST TO
BE TRAINED IN AN AREA BUT TO
REALLY HAVE A CERTIFICATION
SOMETHING LIKE AUTO MECHANICS
TO WALK OUTSIDE AND SAY THERE'S
NO HOW TO REPAIR A MOTOR BUT I
HAVE AN EIGHT THE CERTIFICATION
I HAVEN'T I CARP CERTIFICATION
SO REALLY INTO INTO A LOT. AND
LATER ALL WITH TECHNOLOGY HAS
BEEN MAJOR STRUGGLE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THAT SOMETHING WITTY
TECHNOLOGY. IN THE SYSTEM THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING GET
OUT. PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
AROUND IN OUR SYSTEM THROUGH
THICK AND THIN WHEN THINGS ARE
CUT AND C. C. R. WHEN THEY'RE
NOT CUT OR TREATMENT PROVIDERS
THAT ARE. I COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND NON PROFITS
THE COMING DELIVER TREATMENT.
THEY BELIEVE IN IT THEY
MOTIVATE ME EVERY DAY TO COME
BACK TO WORK BECAUSE OF WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO. IN A
SYSTEM THAT WE'VE HEARD. IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO DO IT WE ARE
A SQUARE PEG IN A ROUND HOLE
AND WE ARE PUSHING OUR WAY AND
BECAUSE REHABILITATION IS SO
IMPORTANT. AND SO I CAN'T GIVE
ENOUGH CREDIT TO THE PEOPLE
THAT COME IN. OFTENTIMES
FINDING OTHER FISCAL RESOURCES
TO COME IN AND CONTINUE DOING
THAT SO. THAT'S A BIG THING
THAT WE REALLY FOCUS WE THINK
IS IMPORTANT SO. WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SAY IN TERMS OF WHAT
I FEEL LIKE IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
RE ENTERING WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
REALLY STAND BEHIND. IS REALLY
COMING IN ASSESSING WHAT PEOPLE
NEED. AND IT'S NOT A IF THEN
STATEMENT. IT'S REALLY
ADDRESSING THE WHOLE PERSON AND
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
NEED. AND SO THEY MIGHT NEED AN
EDUCATION OR THEY MIGHT NEED TO
CAREER TECHNICAL TRADE. THEY
ALSO NEED TIME IN THE EVENING
TO ENJOY OTHER PEOPLE'S COMPANY
WORK ON COMMUNICATION. DO YOU
AYE YOGA GARDENING ALL OF THESE
THINGS. A PERSONAL STORY MY
BLOOD PRESSURE IS THROUGH THE
ROOF. AND SO I DIDN'T STOP
GOING TO COLLEGE BECAUSE MY
BLOOD PRESSURE WAS THROUGH THE
ROOF I STARTED DOING YOGA. SO
NOW YOU FINISH COLLEGE AND YOU
DO YOGA IN THE EVENINGS. AND
THE BLOOD PRESSURE HAS COME
DOWN AND I THINK OUR POPULATION
EXISTS THE SAME. WE'VE HEARD IT
TODAY. A RE ENTRY STARTS FROM
RECEPTION. RE ENTRY IS REALLY
ABOUT ADDRESSING THE ENTIRE
PERSON. AND IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE A DICHOTOMY OF. THIS OR THAT
BUT I'M REALLY FOCUSING ON
GIVING PEOPLE. EVERYTHING THAT
THEY NEED WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE REHABILITATION. IN
A ROBUST WAY. AND THEN BRIEFLY
SPEAKING ARE MIL COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAMS THAT FORMER
SECRETARY KATE DISCUSS. THOSE
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT COMMUNITY
CONNECTIONS AND GIVING THOSE
COMMUNITY CONNECTIONS TO PEOPLE
SO THAT THEY CAN. REINTEGRATE
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY IN A
POSITIVE WAY. AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY ARE COMING BACK IN.
AND THEN FOLLOWING UP YOU KNOW
IT'S ONE TREATMENT EPISODE IN
TWO LOCATIONS IS HOW WE THINK
ABOUT IT REHABILITATION. IT
STARTS ON THE INSIDE BUT IT
ENDS ON THE OUTSIDE. AND JUST
TO BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT SOME
SOMETHING ELSE AND YOUR P. THAT
WE THINK IS IMPORTANT. IN IN
LATE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN EARLY
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE SAT
DOWN AS AN EXECUTIVE TEAM AND
REALLY SAID. WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON QUALITY. WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO FOCUS ON
DATA COLLECTION SO WE-
UNDERTOOK A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES THAT END UP. A
REALLY KIND OF PLAYS OUT IN
CONVERSATIONS TODAY AND WHAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING. REALLY TO
TRY AND PROVE. THAT WE CAN. DO
THIS AND IT DOES. WORK IF IT'S
DONE CORRECTLY IN IN THE RIGHT
SYSTEM SO. I WANTED TO BRIEFLY
TALK ABOUT THAT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEDICATION ARE OVER
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WHICH WAITED OVER
SECOND SORRY I'LL BE WORKING
OFF THIS HAND OUT IMPROVING IN
PRISON REHABILITATION. PROGRAMS
SO GOING ON OF THE FIRST PAGE
IN DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
OUR OFFICE RELEASED A REPORT
IDENTIFYING SEVERAL
SHORTCOMINGS AND REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY THAT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
THE STATE AUDIT ARE ALSO
IDENTIFIED SIMILAR SHORTCOMINGS
IN AN AUDIT RELEASED IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY NINETEEN. AND ARTICLE
IS FOUND THAT THAT PROGRAMS ARE
NOT EVIDENCE BASED SOME
PROGRAMS ON EVIDENCE BASED
BECAUSE THEY ARE BASED OFF OF
MODELS HAVE NOT BEEN SHOWN TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM. AND EVEN IN
CASES WHERE THEY ARE HAVE YOU
SEE OUR DOES NOT CALL ME VALUE
IT WHETHER THEY OPERATE WITH
FIDELITY TO THOSE MODELS
SECOND. PROGRAMS IN ARE NOT
EFFECTIVELY TARGETED AT HIGH
RISK HIGH NEED IN EIGHT. FOR
EXAMPLE MANY INMATES WITH HIGH
RATE THE NEEDS ARE THESE
WITHOUT HAVING DIDN'T RECEIVE
ANY OF THE NEEDED PROGRAMS
DESPITE THOUSANDS OF LOW RISK
AND LOW NEED INMATES BEING
ASSIGNED MORE OVERT THIS
DOESN'T TOOL USED TO ASSIGN THE
INMATES MY NOT REALLY
IDENTIFIED ON THE- GIVEN THAT
IT WAS CREATED WITH DATA THAT
IS NOW OVER TEN YEARS OLD. WAIT
LET IT. MANY PROGRAMS OUGHT TO
REMAIN VACANT AND MOREOVER MANY
ENROLLED IN MADE DO NOT
ACTUALLY ATTEND THE PROGRAMS.
AND FINALLY THE PROGRAMS ARE
SUBJECT TO FLAWED PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT THESE ALL BLACKS KEY
PERFORMANCE MEASURES. SUCH AS
THE LATE THE PARTICIPATION
BEFORE THESE AND IN ADDITION
SOME METRICS ARE MISLEADING FOR
EXAMPLE MEANINGFUL
PARTICIPATION IS DEFINED AS
BEING ENROLLED FOR THIRTY DAYS
REGARDLESS OF PROGRAM LANE. OR
THE ACTUAL ATTENDANCE RATE.
THESE ARE HAS TAKEN SOME STRESS
TO ADDRESS THESE SHORTCOMINGS
RIGHT HAS SPOKEN ABOUT SOME OF
THEM BUT FOR EXAMPLE CITIES ARE
HAS STATED THAT IT WILL REQUIRE
CONTRACTOR THAT PROVIDE SOME
SERVICES TO USE MODELS SHOWN TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM. AND IT IS
IMPLEMENTED IMPLEMENTING
FIDELITY ASSESSMENT FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. THE JUDGE ALSO SAY
THAT IT'S TAKEN STEPS TO BETTER
TARGET IN MADE INCLUDING. FOR
THE GUIDANCE TO INMATE
ASSIGNMENT OFFICERS. I MEAN
WHETHER TO SEVEN TOOLS SHOULD
BE RE VALIDATED OR REPLACED.
AND CONTINUED EFFORTS TO REDUCE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF PROGRAMS
BEING SHUT DOWN DUE TO A LACK
OF STAFF. WE WOULD RECOMMEND
TAKING SOME ADDITIONAL STEPS TO
IMPROVE REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
FIRST WE WOULD RECOMMEND
REQUIREMENT THAT PROGRAMS BE
EVIDENCE BASED TO DO THIS. WE
RECOMMEND DIRECTING TV ARE TO
REPORT WHETHER EACH
REHABILITATION PROGRAM IS BASED
ON RESEARCH SHOWING IT IS
EFFECTIVE. THE LEGISLATURE
COULD MAKE THIS A CONDITION FOR
ON GOING FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THAT THE PROGRAM SHOULD BE
INDEPENDENTLY EVALUATED BY THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTED WITH FIDELITY. WE
ALSO RECOMMEND HAVING
INDEPENDENT RESEARCHERS
EVALUATE THE COST EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
WE KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED EIGHTY SIXTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. WHICH WOULD HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED THIS BUT IT WAS
RECENTLY VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR.
THIRTY WE RECOMMEND MORE
EFFECTIVELY TARGETING PROGRAMS
YOUR HIGH RISK HIGH NEED
INMATES RECOMMEND ESTABLISHING
A REVIEW COMMITTEE INCLUDING X.
DONALD J. COLE OR AN EXPERT. TO
USE SELECT THE ASSESSMENT TOOLS
MOST EFFECTIVE IDENTIFYING HIGH
RISK HIGH NEED IN ME. JUNE
SHORT CD SHOP PRIORITIZE HIGH
RISK HIGH NEED IN MADE WE ALSO
RECOMMEND TALKING STOCK YOU
DIRECTING IT TO DO SO. FOURTH
WE RECOMMEND IMPROVING
EFFICIENT USE OF EXISTING
REHABILITATION RESOURCES.
RECOMMEND DIRECTING TV STAR TO
ASSESS THE FACILITIES TO
IDENTIFY THE RESOURCES
REQUIRED. TO MEET ALL THE NEEDS
OF HIGH RISK HIGH NEED IN A- WE
ALSO RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
INCORPORATE ACTUAL INMATE
ATTENDANCE INTO PROGRAM FUNDING
DECISIONS TO MINIMUM. LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF SLOTS ARE NOT USED
EFFICIENTLY. FIFTH WE RECOMMEND
IMPROVING PERFORMANCE MEASURES
TO CONDUCT REGULAR OVERSIGHT IN
ORDER TO ENABLE REGULAR PROGRAM
OVERSIGHT WE RECOMMEND
DIRECTING TV SEE ARE YOU
IMPROVING REPORT ON CERTAIN
PERFORMANCE MEASURES INCLUDING
THE PERCENTAGE OF INMATES WITH
UNMET NEEDS THE OWNER LAYS.
FINALLY WE'LL NOTE THAT
CONTINUE TREATMENT UPON RELEASE
CAN HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON REBUILD WE ABILITY ASIAN. WE
ARE CURRENTLY LOOKING INTO
PROGRAMS OFFERED THROUGH CDC
ARE IN THE COMMUNITY AND WHAT
THEIR FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THOSE IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU AND HAVE
ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
AFTERNOON I'M ROY WESLEY I'M
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR THE
STATE OR JURISDICTION IS
OVERSIGHT OF THE PRISON SYSTEM.
AND WITH REGARD TO
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING. WE
PRIMARILY LOOK AT. ABOUT A
TWICE A YEAR AUDIT OF HOW THE
PROGRAMS ARE. I ROLLED OUT SO
TWICE HERE WE GO OUT AND COUNT
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN SEATS
COUNT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
COMPLETED THAT SORT OF THING.
OUR MISSION IS TRANSPARENCY SO
UNLIKE THE DEPARTMENT WHICH IS
THE HANDS ON WHO'S ON THE
GROUND ORGANIZATION. OUR JOB IS
TO GO INTO A CLOSED SYSTEM THAT
IS NOT OPEN TO THE PUBLIC AND
PROVIDE SOME. INFORMATION TO
THE PUBLIC TO TELL YOU ALL WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT'S DOING. WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH RYAN'S TEAM WE
HAVE A ORGANIZATION CALLED THE
REHABILITATION OVERSIGHT BOARD.
THAT MEETS ABOUT THREE TIMES A
YEAR IT'S GOT EXPERTS FROM
AROUND THE STATE THAT MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING. AND THE RESPONSE
BY THE DEPARTMENT HAS BY AND
LARGE BEEN VERY GOOD THEY HAVE
A LOT OF SMART PEOPLE INCLUDING
RYAN AT THE SHOE DEPARTMENT AND
THEY PUT A LOT OF THOUGHT IN
THE PROGRAMS. WHERE THE WHERE
THE PROBLEM COMES IS THE
EXECUTION OF THE FIELD. OF WHAT
WE FIND IS THAT THE EXECUTION
IS. SPOT IS UNEVEN AND THE. THE
DEMAND BY THE HEADQUARTERS THAT
WE GET THE RIGHT INMATES IN THE
RIGHT SEATS AND THAT WE WANT
ALL THE SEATS FILLED TURNS INTO
I GOT TO HAVE PEOPLE IN SEATS
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE AND SO WE SEE PEOPLE FOR
EXAMPLE AND TRANSITIONS CLASSES
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
LAST SIX MONTHS YOU'RE IN
PRISON PREPARING YOU TO GO OUT
INTO. FREE SOCIETY WITH PEOPLE
WHO HAVE SIX NEW YEARS LEFT ON
THEIR SENSE. OF. THAT IS THE
CHALLENGE THE DEPARTMENT FACES
AND THE WE TRY TO. MAKE SURE
THAT THE PUBLIC AND OUR
LEGISLATORS KNOW IS HAPPENING
OUT ON THE GROUND LOOK. I THINK
THAT. EVERYBODY IS. IS TRYING
THEIR BEST TO MAKE THE SYSTEM
WORK IT'S THAT. HOW THAT
EXECUTION ACTUALLY HAPPENS AT
THE INSTITUTION IS DIFFICULT TO
MANAGE AND WHEN YOU'VE GOT A
SPAN OF CONTROL THIRTY FOUR
PRISONS AND LITERALLY OVER A
THOUSAND PROGRAMS. IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO HAVE THAT
CONSISTENCY STATEWIDE OUR
OFFICE HAS VERY SMALL
OVERSIGHT. PIECE OF THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE WE DO NOT HAVE PEOPLE
IN THE IN THE FIELD. ON ON A
REGULAR BASIS WELL REGULAR
BASIS IS TWICE A YEAR BUT
THAT'S. THAT KIND OF OVERSIGHT.
IS WHAT'S NECESSARY AND IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE DONE BY MY
OFFICE IT CAN BE DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT IT CAN BE DONE BY
OTHER AGENCIES BUT THERE HAS TO
BE A RECOGNITION THAT. THE
VISION THAT HAPPENS IN
HEADQUARTERS HAS TO. BE CARRIED
OUT AT THE AT THE LOCAL. SO
THANK YOU IN A. ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. I WAS JUST WONDERING
IF. CDC ARE HAD A RESPONSE TO
SOME OF THE LA THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU. SAW THEM EARLIER BUT JUST.
ESPECIALLY ON PAGE THREE IN
TERMS OF JUST THE- SOME OF.
NEXT STEPS THAT THEY'RE
RECOMMENDING. THANK YOU I AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO SOMEBODY I THINK
THAT RIGHT CRITICISM FROM FROM
THE LA SO I'LL CALL
CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM AND THE
LEGISLATURE IS. ACT ABSOLUTELY
CITIES ARE START TIME
STRUGGLING DATE AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WHAT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND THAT IS A LOT OF THE
IN IT. THAT WE PUT IN PLACE A
COUPLE YEARS SO I'M A QUICKLY
JUST GO THROUGH BALL BY BALL IT
IF THAT'S OKAY PLEASE SO.
REQUIRE PROGRAMS WE HAVE IN
SPACE SO WE'VE ALWAYS HAD THE
REQUIREMENT THAT ARE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS ACADEMIC EDUCATION AND
CAREER TECHNICAL PROGRAMS BE
EVIDENCE BASED WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED COLLECTING EVIDENCE
BASED INFORMATION WE WERE
COLLECTING EVERYTHING THAT
PEOPLE WERE USING AND NOT JUST
THE PRIMARY CURRICULUMS ARE
SECONDARY CREEK AND
UNDERSTANDING HOW THINGS WERE
LAYER. SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE
DID WORK WITH A FEW RESULTS
FIRST AND IN THAT IN THAT WORK
WHEN WE CAME OUT WE WANT TO
PUBLISH IT WE WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT I DID A COLLECTION
ABOUT 7275% WERE. NOTED AS NOT
BEING EVIDENCE BASED CURRICULUM
NOT THAT IT WAS FOUND TO BE
NEGATIVE JUST THAT IT WASN'T IN
THE RESULTS FIRST CLEARING
HOUSE OR HAD NOT BEEN
RESEARCHED. SO WE THOUGHT
WHAT'S OUR FIRST INITIATIVE IS
TAKE IT REALLY KIND OF MAKE
SURE THAT ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS
EVIDENCE BASED SO WE'VE PUT OUT
POLICY WITH ARE IN PRISON
PROGRAMS EVEN AS OF RECENTLY
FORCING THEM TO USE CURRICULUM
IS WITHIN THE RESULTS FIRST
CLEARING HOUSE. SO WHEN YOU
LOOK AT OUR PRIMARY CURRICULUM
FOR IN PRISON PROGRAMS NOW THE
LAST I CHECKED WAS ABOUT 95%
WAS USING EVIDENCE BASED
CURRICULUM IN THE RESULTS FIRST.
CLEARING HOUSE. AS BEING
EFFECTIVE. THE SECOND PIECE OF
THAT IS. WE ALSO DON'T WANT TO
HARM. PROGRAMS SURROUNDING AT
ITS BASE THE DISCUSSION IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. FOR US. IN
SAYING OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PEOPLE TO
COME IN THE PRISONS THAT ARE
DOING THINGS LIKE YOGA. THAT
ARE DOING THINGS LIKE. YOU KNOW
REALLY COMMUNICATION
EFFECTIVENESS REALLY RICH
FAMILY REUNIFICATION. WE NEED
DATA. BEFORE WE SAY THAT
THEY'RE NOT EFFECTIVE AND SO
THOSE PROGRAMS. NOT THAT
THEY'RE NOT EVIDENCE BASED. AND
I DON'T THINK THAT WE FEEL LIKE
THEY SHOULD GO AWAY THEY
PROVIDE A REALLY HOLISTIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE. OTHER THINGS. SO
THOSE ARE OFF THE SIDE WE HAVE
RESEARCH AND IF THE-
INITIATIVES AROUND SO. OUR
PROGRAMS TREATMENT EDUCATION.
AND CAREER TECHNICAL ARE REALLY
FOCUS ON BEING OUT IN SPACE AND
THAT THE SECONDARY PROGRAMS WE
WANT TO GIVE RESEARCH
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH I THINK
WILL BE. AND THE SECOND OVER
HERE. THE MEASURE COST
EFFECTIVENESS I SAID THAT
STARTED WITH YOU BUT- THAT HAS
BEEN A BIG INITIATIVE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. AND WE CONTINUE ON
THROUGH CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE- RECTIFIER
SECRETARY INTERNALLY WE WANT TO
PROVE THAT IT WORKS. NATIONAL
YOU SEE EDUCATION WORKING.
NATIONALLY YOU SEE ARTS
PROGRAMS. WORKING IN SOME
RESPECTS NATIONALLY YOU SEE
SUBSTANCE USE PROGRAMS WORKING
WHEN DELIVERED EFFECTIVELY. AND
SO WE ARE PARTNERING WITH
RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS NOW. TO
BOTH CREATE FOUNDATIONAL
PRACTICES TO MAKE SURE DOING IT
RIGHT. AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
OUTCOMES WORK. AND THAT JUST
MEANS DATA COLLECTION AND SOME
TIME BUT WE ARE DOING THAT. AS
OF TODAY I'LL MENTION TO. THREE
FUNDS. OKAY SORRY. YES SORRY
ABOUT THAT. WE'RE WORKING WITH
YOU SEE I TO CREATE FIDELITY
TOOLS AND WE'RE ALSO DOING
SOMETHING WITH PP I SEE IN A
VERY LONGITUDINAL STUDY TO MAKE
SURE THINGS ARE WORKING WE HAVE
INITIATIVES GOING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY AS ORGANIZATIONS
AFFECTED WITH TARGETING YES FOR
USING TECHNOLOGY WE'RE TRYING
TO NOT MAKE IT A GROUND LEVEL
THING AND SAY FOLLOW TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGY IS VERY SMART AND DO
THE RIGHT FORMULAS AND USS
PEOPLE CORRECTLY. AND THAT GOES
TO THE LIGHTER TO REALLY TO IS
WE PUT IN PLACE PROGRAM
ACCOUNTABILITY INFIDELITY
REVIEWS FOR TREATMENT WE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE
SAYS START CONNECTING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO CREATE PRE AND POST SURVEYS
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF INITIATIVES
THAT WERE REALLY PUTTING
FORWARD AS AS CRITICAL SO THAT
WE CAN PROVE THAT WE'RE DOING
REHABILITATION CORRECTLY WE'RE
GIVING. EVERYONE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVE THAT THEY
ARE DOING IT CORRECTLY AS WELL.
I WANT TO THANK THIS PANEL.
SURE WE GET ASKED A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AND WE PROBABLY WILL
DO IN THE YEAR. WE HAVE OUR
HEARINGS IN SACRAMENTO OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY. HOWEVER I WANT
TO GIVE THOSE OF YOU IN THE
AUDIENCE IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION
WE DON'T A MICROPHONE UP THERE.
BUT YOU WANNA COME FORWARD AND
GIVE US THAT QUESTION. WELL
TAKE TWO OR THREE QUESTIONS AT
THE MOST BECAUSE THAT TIME IS
ALMOST UP. SO IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION NOW ONE. ON YOU KNOW I
WAS JUST IF THAT'S MY STUDENTS.
A QUESTION YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
BIG PREAMBLE TO A QUESTION. YES
THEY- DO THIS THAT WHATEVER
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. DON'T GIVE
US A LONG BACKGROUND. STORY
OTHERWISE WOULD PROBABLY ONLY
HEAR ONE PERSON. OKAY. YOUR
QUESTION. MY NAME'S GRAHAM FROM
JOHN WITH INITIATE JUSTICE I'M
ALSO PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED.
MY EXPERIENCE WITH
INCARCERATION WAS THAT THE
PROGRAMS WHILE THEY WERE BEING
OFFERED IN THESE LAST COUPLE
YEARS. I WAS INCARCERATED FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS THEY WERE
OFFERED IN THE- BEGINNING
TWELVE. AND NOW THEY ARE
OFFERED SO MY QUESTION WOULD
BE. THE INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
OFFERED IN OUR- ARE. MOSTLY
LOWER LEVEL ONE TO LEVEL ONE
LEVEL TWO PRISONS WITCHER.
MEDIUM OR LOW SECURITY. WHY ARE
THESE PROGRAMS NOT BEING
OFFERED TO THE HIGHER SECURITY
INMATES WHO. ARE GOING TO BOARD
AT THE SAME RATE THAT PEOPLE ON
LOWER FACILITIES ARE GOING. AND
ARE COMING UP FOR RELEASE AND
THEY NEED THOSE PROGRAMS TO
COMPLETE BOARD. OKAY THANK YOU
ANYONE HAVE A RESPONSE TO THAT.
I COULDN'T BRIEFLY RESPOND
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS HISTORICALLY NOT
PUT. PROGRAMS AT ALL LEVELS IN
NAMELY CAREER TECHNICAL
PROGRAMS THINGS LIKE WELDING
AND STUFF LIKE THAT. WE DO HAVE
ACADEMIC EVERYWHERE WE'VE
ACTUALLY PUT OUT GRANTS THAT
ARE DIRECTLY FOCUSED ON
CERTAIN. FACILITIES THAT ARE
HIGHER LEVEL FACILITIES. AND WE
CONTINUE TO FOCUS THAT BECAUSE
WE THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE FAIR AND
EQUITABLE ACCESS ANY OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS EVERY DAY. THAT
MEANS CHANGING POLICY AND DOING
THINGS THAT APARTMENTS NEVER
DONE BEFORE. IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT
OKAY THE NEXT PERSON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS DIANA
CRUISES I AM EIGHT. I HAVE A
LOVED ONE IN IN ONE OF THESE
PRISONS. AND HEARING A LOT
ABOUT PROGRAMMING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN SENTENCING
BUT MAINLY ABOUT PROGRAMMING.
BUT HOW CAN CDC ARE SAY IT'S
OFFERING ALL THESE PROGRAMS
WHEN IN THE LAST YEAR THERE'S
BEEN ALL THESE GLADIATOR FIGHTS
AND OUR LOVED ONES ARE LOCKED
DOWN. SEVEN TO TEN MONTHS NO
PROGRAMMING NOTHING IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND YOU GUYS
CONTINUE TO PUSH THE NON
DESIGNATED PROGRAMMING
FACILITIES. THE INCREMENTAL
RELEASES THAT IS. VIOLENCE IN
THE PRISONS THEY DON'T HAVE A
CHOICE THE YOU KNOW AND THEN
THERE BEING PLACED AN AD SAY
THEY'RE BEING PLACE. YOU KNOW
GIVEN DA REFERRALS FOR TEN TO
MYRTLE ATTEMPTED MURDER I MEAN
EVERYTHING IS NEGATIVE ABOUT
REHABILITATION AND PROGRAMMING
IN THE PRISONS SINCE LAST YEAR
SINCE KATHLEEN. ALISON DID YOU
GET THE QUESTION REAL QUICK. I
MEAN STILL YOU'RE TAMI
PROGRAMMING BUT I DON'T SEE IT
WOULD THESE GLADIATOR FIGHTS SO
HOW CAN YOU TELL ME THEIR
INMATES ARE PROGRAMMING OR THAT
YOU'RE OFFERING OR OUR LOVED
ONES PROGRAMS WHEN THEY ARE.
LET'S GET THE QUESTION YOU WANT
TO KNOW ARE THEY OFFERING
PROGRAMS HOW ARE YOU OFFERING
THE PROGRAMS WITH THESE
GLADIATOR FIGHTS IN THESE
LOCKED OKAY FINE THANK YOU
ANYONE IT WOULD RESPONSE. IT'S
GOING TO BE OUTSIDE MY POLICY.
OKAY OKAY MISTER WESLEY. SO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE INCREMENTAL
RELEASES HAVE BEEN A PROBLEM
I'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH
SECRETARY TO USE THOSE HAVE
STOPPED REALLY HAVE NO. OKAY
OKAY LET HIM LET HIM GIVE HIS
RESPONSE OKAY LET HIM HAVE HIS.
WE LET HIM HAVE HIS RESPONSE
PLEASE RENTAL RELEASES HAVE
BEEN STOPPED AND THOSE THERE IS
A REEVALUATION OF HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO GO FORWARD WITH THAT
AND THAT'S THAT'S REALLY
SOMETHING FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
FIGURE OUT WE'VE GIVEN THEM
SOME. SOME RECOMMENDATIONS AND
AT THIS POINT. I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY'RE GOING. WE'LL HEAR
FROM SOMEONE ELSE HI MY NAME IS
MARY MARINO AND JUST TO PIGGY
BACK ON WHAT YOU JUST SAID.
THEIR THEIR POLICY IS THAT.
THEY'RE GOING TO DO A PERIOD
BUT MISSILE MEAL STATED A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT CDC ARE WILL
USE THEIR AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE
CREDITS THE PROBLEM LIES ON HOW
CDC ARE USES THAT AUTHORITY.
AND THEREFORE IT SHOULD BE YOUR
NUMBER ONE CONCERN TO HAVE
PROVIDE A ROBUST OVERSIGHT THAT
WORK SIDE BY SIDE WITH THE YG
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THESE
PRACTICES ARE APPROPRIATE. NOW
A NUMBER TWO SHOULD BE AUDITS
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO GIVE US
A QUESTION. ABOUT IN A
STATEMENT BECAUSE I MY QUESTION
MY QUESTION WOULD BE DO YOU.
DOES IT NOT SOUND LIKE THIS
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO PROVIDE
AND A ROBUST OVERSIGHT THAT CDC
ARE HAS NOT HAVE OR YEARS WANT
TO NOTICE THE CDC ARE HAVE A
ROBUST OVERSIGHT THAT'S A
QUESTION I LIMITED. VERY
LIMITED OVER SO I CAN TAKE THAT
OKAY YES. TWO WEEKS AGO THAT
GAVE OUR OFFICE NOW THIRTY TO
INITIATE INDEPENDENT. AUDITS SO
WE ARE CURRENTLY BUILDING TO
OUR TEAMS TO GO OUT TO THE
INSTITUTIONS AND- IT TAKES
AWHILE TO HIGHER ORDERS AND GET
ALL THE PROCESS BUT THESE WILL
BE ROBUST. YELLOWBOOK AUDITS OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE LOOK AT. IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COULD WE
HAVE THE NEXT PERSON I HAVE ONE
MORE QUESTION AND IT HAS TO BE
A QUESTION I'M COULD YOU TAKING
UP EVERYONE'S TIME BEHIND AND
WE NOT ONLY HAVE. THE LAST
QUESTION WOULD JUST BE
PRISONERS USED TO HAVE A UNION.
AND THEY NO LONGER HAVE IT SO
WHAT IN IT ALSO MAKES SENSE FOR
THEM TO HAVE A UNION. THAT
REPRESENTS THEM INSIDE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT QUESTION.
LARRY JOHNSON VASCULAR HERE AND
I'VE BEEN OPERATING IN THE
EVERYBODY HAVE ONE QUESTION
WELL OKAY YEARS DRUG PROGRAM
AND THE MAN CAME OUT THE LIVE
VERSION OF THAT. THE JUDGE
SENTENCING WHAT'S BEING WORKED
ON WITH THE JUDGE SENTENCING I
KNOW SOME OF THE FOLKS IF YOU
ASK WHAT. THE QUESTION IS WHAT
ARE THEY DOING WITH THE JUDGES.
TO CHANGE THE SENTENCING
GUIDELINES. LIKE WHAT THE
SENTENCING GUIDELINE WHEN YOU
GO IN YOUR GIVEN TWELVE YEARS
IN PRISON TEN YEARS AND TEN OF
IT IF IT'S TWELVE TEN AND TWO
IN A DRUG PROGRAM AND THAT AND
SO THEY'RE ONLY GETTING SIX
MONTHS WHEN THEY GOT IT IS
ANYTHING WORKING TO CHANGE THE
SIX MONTH RULE. I'D I WOULD
HAVE TO GET BACK WITH THE I
DON'T HAVE IT THEY'LL GET BACK
TO YOU IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY WE-
WE'VE DONE SOME WORK IN TERMS
OF SENTENCING REFORM. AND I
WORK CONTINUES SO I'M NOT SURE
IF IT IF IT WERE FOR THE
DRESSES YOUR SPECIFIC ISSUE OF
THE RATIO OF ITS THE YEARS YEAH
WE JUST LIKE TWENTY YEARS IN
PRISON AND YOU GET SIX MONTHS
IN A PROGRAM AND- I'LL BUY OUT
OF BALANCE. WELL I THINK YEAH
AND I THINK THE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
ROBUST THAN THEY ONCE WERE.
OKAY I OPERATE ALL RIGHT LET'S
HAVE NEXT PERSON. HI AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I'M WANTING
TO KNOW THAT BEFORE WE TAKE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS OR MOVE FORWARD
WITH WHAT COMES OUT OF THE-
REPORTING. ON REFURBISHING A
REBUILDING THE TWELVE ALL OF
THESE PRISONS IN THE STATE.
COULD THERE BE A REQUIRED
REPORTING ON LIKE A FIVE YEAR
PLAN TO SHUT DOWN THE TROUBLED
IS PRESENT IN THE STATE BEFORE.
LIKE MOVING FORWARD WITH THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REFURBISH A
REBUILD UPSET TO EUROPE POINT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. SURE I'M
SURE WE WILL DO THAT OKAY.
THANK YOU. HELLO THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND SO MY QUESTION IS
ON PROGRAMMING FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS. YOU SPEAK ABOUT
THAT THERE IS PROGRAM IN AND
ALL THE INSTITUTIONS AND THAT
THEY GET TO GO PROGRAM TO GET
THE EDUCATIONAL YOU KNOW THE
KIND AT. THAT BUT AT THE FORMER
INCARCERATED WOMAN AND THAT'S
THE WIFE OF A MAN AS SOON OUT
IN CUSTOMER TIME FOR OVER
TWENTY THREE YEARS. HE HASN'T
REALLY GOTTEN ANY PROGRAMS SO
WHAT DO YOU SUGGEST THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO PROGRAMS IN
A LEVEL FOR. THAT WILL HELP IN
BRINGING. DOWN DAY POINTS TO
COME DOWN TO A LOWER LEVEL.
EVER PRISON WE DISCOVER TODAY
HAS A DIFFERENT SET OF
PROGRAMS. THAT NOT ALL WHERE WE
WANT THEM TO BE. AND WE TALK TO
THOSE OF TAUGHT BY LEVEL FOR
MOVING TO LEVEL THREE AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON SO. IF THIS IS
NEW AND MANY AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF WOOD DISCOVERING AT PRISONS
THAT THEY ALL VERY SOME HAVE.
GREAT PROGRAMS SOME HAVE VERY
FEW PROGRAMS WE WENT TODAY SOME
A GRAPPLING WITH THE ISSUES
THAT YOU RACES AND WAS RAISED
BY SOMEONE ELSE UP YOU TO IN
TERMS OF. WHEN FOLKS ARE IN
THOSE PROGRAMS AND THOSE KIND
OF THINGS SO WE'RE WORKING ON
IT. IT IS BY NO MEANS PERFECT
IN EVERY PRISON DOESN'T HAVE
WHAT EVERY PRISONER NEAT. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
GET THE- CITY SEE STAFFING.
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE GOING
TO BE IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS TO PLEASE CONSIDER
STOPPING THE INTEGRATION OF THE
ARTS BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL
BEING INTEGRATED. AND DONE THAT
CAN AFFECT THEIR PLANS OF
COMING HOME. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS EMILY HARRIS AND
WITH THE ELEVATOR CENTER AND MY
QUESTION IS YOU'VE GOT ABOUT
FIVE MORE MINUTES. WILL RELATE
THEM OUT HERE OKAY SO MY
QUESTION IS TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ABOUT. ASKING YOU ALL
TO WORK WITH US TO HOLD ANOTHER
HEARING. THAT WOULD BE. WITH
PANELS THAT ARE MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE FOLKS
WHO. HAVE BEEN IN PRISON I KNOW
I'VE WORKED ON ALL OF THOSE
ENHANCEMENT. IN SENTENCE
REFORMS THAT YOU'VE ALL TALKED
ABOUT AND MY BEST GUIDES HAVE
BEEN WHEN I WORKED. MOST
DIRECTLY WITH PEOPLE INSIDE AND
PEOPLE WHO'VE DONE THE TIME AND
HAVE FIGURED OUT HOW TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. THEY SHOULD BE THE
ONES ON ALL THESE PANELS GIVING
YOU ALL THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
WELL WE'VE HAD MORE THAN ONE
PANEL FIRST OF ALL YOU SHOULD
KNOW THAT IN MANY OF THE PANELS
DO HAVE THOSE WHO ADVOCATE TO
DO WORK IN THE PRISONS AND WHO
ARE THE- NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND WORK DIRECTLY WITH
THEM IN FACT. WE HEAR FROM THEM
MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE AND SO
THIS IS JUST A SMALL SAMPLING.
WE HAD DAY BECAUSE WE WERE HIT
DONOVAN TO DEAL WITH THAT. THE
PRESIDENT DOWN UP AND A
PERSON'S OVERALL. PERMITS THE
INFORMATION WE NEEDED. BUT IN
SACRAMENTO THE HEARINGS ARE
MUCH MORE ROBUST. AND A LOT OF
THE ADVOCATES ARE THE YEAR. AND
REPRESENTING THE VARIOUS
PROGRAM SO WE DO DO THAT BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UHHUH YES.
I AM SURE KANSEN AND I'M MY
QUESTION IS HOW WHAT'S THE TIME
FRAME I SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
ARE YOU LOOKING AT TO. GET
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT OUT OF
THE PRISON INTO COMMUNITY BASED
TREATMENT OPPORTUNITY. WEIRD
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE DOING WOULD WORK ON
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IN THE
COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES WE HAVE
GIVEN SOME FUNDING TO OUR
COUNTIES TO BEGIN TO WORK WITH
US IN TERMS OF REHABILITATION
BUT THOSE WHO ARE COMING OUT.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT OBVIOUS
THAT OPTION IN SENTENCING THOSE
WOULD NOT INCARCERATED BUT WHO
NEED MENTAL HEALTH SO WE'RE
WORKING ON THOSE ISSUES AND I'M
WE'RE- WORKING WITH OUR COUNTY
BECAUSE OUR COUNTY IS A LITTLE
BE. BIT BEHIND IF THE ELSE'S IN
TERMS OF PROGRAMS AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT AND SO WE'RE
WORKING ON TRYING TO GET THAT
MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUE ADDRESSED
IN OUR COUNTY IT SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AS WELL AS OTHERS. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WE'RE
WE'RE OF IT. THANK YOU. ALWAYS
READ OKAY. A JUST SO YOU KNOW
IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET ITSELF
WE'VE BEEN A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN MENTAL HEALTH DIVERT
THEIR PROGRAM. SO DO WE SHOULD
BE SEEING THAT SOON. OKAY DA
DOES MUSEUM THINKING CORRECT
DARK IMMIGRATION WE WOULD LIKE
LEGISLATURE TO DO A MOMENT
MORATORIUM. TO DO THE RESEARCH
ON YARD INTEGRATION AND. REYES
AND I THINK I KNOW WHY. I WOULD
LIKE THAT PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUEST ACT I'M EXCITED. SIX
TWO FIVE WAS THE M. K. NINE OF
THEM SO YOU CAN'T. GIVE REYES
WE NEED TO BE TRANSPLANT
BECAUSE OF DAILY. THANK YOU.
NEXT QUESTION WOULD WOULD
TRYING TO GET OUT OF HERE SO I
UNDERSTAND MY NAME IS FLOWER
OPERATES AND WITH YOUR
PERMISSION CAN I DON'T EITHER
THERE'S ANOTHER EVENT COMING IN
HERE SO WE REALLY FIVE MINUTES
AND WE'RE OUT OKAY WOULD YOU
ALLOW ME TO ADD THREE SENTENCES
OF CONTEXT BEFORE MY QUESTION
I'M FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND I
HAVE MY HAS BEEN AND OTHER FOR
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS
IMPRISONED I HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS AND CDC ARM.
I HAVE TO ACCEPT COLLECT CALLS
AND I USE NOW IS THE BIGGEST
FORM OF COMMUNICATION AND THE
AGE OF TECHNOLOGY OUR
EXPERIENCES DEALING WITH CDC
OURS DRAMATIC WHETHER WE'RE THE
ONES THAT ARE LOCKED UP OR NOT
I. SUGGEST WE START WITH
COOKING PELICAN BAY MY. REALLY
GOING TO DO TO. ENSURE WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD TO
MOVE FORWARD AND IN THE CHAPTER.
MASS INCARCERATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON SORRY
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DOCTOR BRIDGET BURDEN AND I
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOR M. C. R.
P. THE PROGRAMS HERE IN SAN
DIEGO WHEN THE GUYS ARE GETTING
THEIR GED CLASSES AND COURSES
THERE'S KNOWN FINDING OUR MONEY
TO FOR TESTING SO ONCE THEY
COMPLETE THEIR COURSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS TO TAKE
THE TEST SO BASICALLY WHAT I'M
ACTION IS ARE YOU GUYS PUT IN
SOME FINANCES ASIDE FOR
EDUCATION. THE G. D. ARE THE
HIGH SET PROGRAM. YES THIS
CONVERSATION JUST CAME UP AND
IT WILL BE ADDRESSED VERY
SHORTLY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS MELISSA LOPEZ MY
HUSBAND'S CURRENY AND I'M A
LEVEL FOUR WITH LEVEL TWO
POINTS DUE TO THE INTEGRATION
HE WAS ALMOST KILLED I WANT TO
KNOW BECAUSE YOU GUYS SO YOU
HOLDING THIS PROGRAM. ALL THESE
GUYS ARE THEN LEVEL FOUR WITH
LEVEL TWO POINTS WHAT DO YOU
GUYS AND DUKE FOR YOUR
EXPERIMENT THAT WENT WRONG
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AND WE
HAVE A PUBLIC SAFETY. HEARING
SO YOU GOT TO GET BACK FROM THE
REAL FAMILIES OF ALL THESE
PEOPLE THAT WERE. IMPACTED HURT
AND LYFT HAVE BEEN ALTERED.
BECAUSE OF THIS EXPERIMENT THE
CDC ARE DEAD. THANK YOU ANY.
COMMENTS WITH SIXTY ARE. THEIR
LIVES ARE IN DANGER. IT WOULD
BE A BETTER OKAY WILL HAVE A.
YOU CAN SUBMIT THE QUESTION TO
US YEAH BECAUSE WE HAVE A
PUBLIC HEARING REGARDING A
PUBLIC SAFETY HEARINGS. FOR THE
FAMILY SO YOU GET TO GET THE
TRUTH OKAY. COULD YOU WAIT JUST
A SECOND OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS I WAS AS HE WAS SAYING
HE NEEDS TO GET THE ANSWERS SO
IT'S MUCH MORE ACCURATE. RIGHT
QUESTION THAT YOU HAVE SO IF
YOU CAN. MY STAFF IS RIGHT NEXT
TO YOU GIVE HER YOUR NAME AND
INFORMATION AND I'LL MAKE SURE
YOU GET THE INFORMATION ALL
RIGHT COULD I HAVE ABOUT TWO
AND A FAMILIES I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE TRUE FACTS.
OKAY HI MY NAME IS LAURA MURRAY
I'M A FIRST YEAR GRAD STUDENT
IN CRIMINOLOGY AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND SAN DIEGO STATE I'M
ALSO FORMALLY INCARCERATED. AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF PROJECT
REBOUNDS STUDENT ALLIANCE AND
THE OUTREACH COORDINATOR
PROJECT REBOUND. WHICH
ADVOCATES FOR THE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED THROUGH THE CSU
SYSTEM. WHAT I'D LIKE TO KNOW
IS I HEARD A LOT ABOUT IT DO
YOU DE AND CARS RATING THE
MAN'S PRISONS BUT I HAVEN'T
HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT D.
INCARCERATING. THE WOMEN'S
PRISONS AS WE ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING POPULATION IN THE CDC
ARE TODAY. AND WHAT KIND OF
PROGRAMS CAN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
GIVE THESE WOMEN THAT ARE
COMING OUT BECAUSE THESE.
PROGRAMS ARE NOT GENDER
SPECIFIC FOR WOMEN THEY'RE
BUILT FOR MAN. SO I'D LIKE TO
SEE MORE PROGRAMS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WITH THREE ENTRY AND
REINTEGRATION INTO SOCIETY.
THANK YOU. THANK WE VISITED
LEAST I HAVE TO THE PRISONS IN
SENEGAL COUNTY THAT ARE WOMEN.
AND THEY'RE PROBABLY FARTHER
AHEAD THAN THE MAN. IN TERMS OF
PROGRAMS. WELL SEE I W. HAS THE
HIGHEST SUICIDE RATE YEAH. YEAH
YEAH AND WE AND WE RECOGNIZE
THE SUICIDE RATE ALSO DEALING
WITH THAT IN TERMS OF. LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS. IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THERE BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR. HI
JACKIE FROM INITIATE JUSTICE.
MY QUESTION IS WHO AND HOW DO
YOU GUYS A GERMAN WHO GETS THE
POSSIBILITY OF. JOINING A
PROGRAM BECAUSE I HAVE A FRIEND
THAT SERVING FIFTY. FIFTY MORE
YEARS AND ANOTHER FRIEND THAT
ABLE TO PAROLE AND THREE. AND
THE ONE THAT ABLE TO PEARL AND
THREE HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET
INTO THAT PROGRAM. SOME LIKE
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN. WE HAVE A
NUMBER IN YEAH WE HAVE AN
ONGOING ISSUE OF PEOPLE BEING
IN THE RIGHT PROGRAMS AND SO
THEN I THINK HE WAS SAYING THAT
THERE THERE WAS INCONSISTENCY
THERE ARE INCONSISTENT SO AGAIN
WE'RE WORKING ON TRYING TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM BECAUSE WE
KNOW WE'RE- WE HAVE FOLKS WHO
SHOULD BE IN CERTAIN PROGRAMS.
THAT LEAVES TOWARDS. THAT END
WE GOT LOTS OF FOLKS IN
PROGRAMS WITH SOMEONE NOT IN
THE CORRECT PROGRAM AND SO MANY
PROGRAMS OF THAT IN THERE RIGHT
WHEN WORKING ON THAT NOW THAT
WAS ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
YEAH YOU WOULD THINK I DON'T
ONE LETTER IN A PROSECUTOR
WOULD HAVE THAT. RIGHT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WORKING. ON THAT NOW
WHERE WHERE. WHERE YOU COME SEE
ME AFTER. WE DON'T LIKE ME OUT
THERE GAP. OKAY YEAH OF MY
HUSBAND'S CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED HE'S AN OLD QUIRK
AND FACILITY THREE C. R.
THEY'VE BEEN ON LOCKDOWN FOR
OVER A YEAR AND A HALF. REGARDS
TO THE- INTEGRATION SO MY
QUESTION IS NUTRITION. WHEN
THEY'RE ON THESE INDEFINITE
LOCKDOWN. ALL THE DEPEND ON HIS
FOOD BECAUSE AS A PUNISHMENT
THEY TAKE AWAY THEIR STORE AND
THEY TAKE AWAY THEIR- PACKAGES
SO. WHY IS IT THAT THE FOOD.
YOU KNOW THE BUDGET GOES UP FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT THE FOOD
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS AND
STAYED THE SAME AND NOW THEY'RE
ONLY GETTING TWO PIECES OF
BREAD. VERSUS FOUR. SO THEY
DEPEND ON THIS FOOD WHEN YOU
BUY. WHEN STATUS ARE HAVE A
MONIES INDEFINITE LOCKDOWN SO
WHY IS THE BUDGET. WHY NOT FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE ACOSTA. LIVING
BUT THE FOOD HAS STAYED THE
SAME FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS. TO
SOMEONE WILL HAVE TO ASK YES.
TWO PART OF THAT IS TO HELP
CONTROL COSTS OF MEDICAL CARE
BUT HE. HE DOESN'T WANT TO WRAP
UP OKAY HOLD UP LET HIM FINISH
HIS STATEMENT PLEASE BUT BUT
THAT'S WHAT DROVE THE CHANGE
NOW WE WERE INVOLVED IN IT I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY HERE IN
THIS PANEL WAS INVOLVED IN IT
BUT I'VE HEARD THOSE
COMPLAINTS. AND THAT WAS THE
EXPLANATION THAT WE WERE
PROVIDED. OUR LAST QUESTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RON
MARYLAND ROSS AND I'M THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR PRACTICAL
REBOUND I'M ALSO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION BUT WHEN
THE PRISONERS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND EXPERTISE TODAY. I
LIKE TO ASK THAT THE HIRING
CRITERIA BE REYES FOR
CORRECTION OFFICERS. AND CDC
ARE SAD. I THINK THE THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
REHABILITATION AND THE CARE OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE. ALMOST
GONE WILL POPULATION WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE
CRITERIA FOR HIRING.
INDIVIDUALS TO CARE FOR THEM
SHOULD BE HIGHER THAN WHAT IT
IS TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WANTED TO I WAS LOOKING OVER
HERE FOR MY FRIEND AND HE WAS
ON THE OTHER SIDE WE HAVE. WITH
US THE ONE OF THE-
ADMINISTRATORS FOR THE CCPOA
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WAS
A STEP AND WALKER HE HAS BEEN
QUITE AN ADVOCATE FOR. REFORM
AND I'M JUST PLEASE AT THE BLUE
LAMP SACRAMENTO THEY TO BE AT
THE. HEARING SO IF YOU WANT TO
THOSE ISSUES THIS WALKER. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET. THIS
IS A PROCESS THAT WE UNDERGO
BECAUSE- WE WANT TO HEAR WHAT'S
GOING ON WE WANT TO HEAR WHERE
WE ARE AND WANT TO VISIT
PLACES. BECAUSE WE BEGIN THIS
PROCESS AGAIN IN DECEMBER
JANUARY. WHERE PEOPLE COMING
FORWARD IDEAS AND BUDGET ITEMS
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. AND
WE'RE GETTING VERY AS AUDITS
AND REPORTS WANNA MAKE SURE
THOSE ARE ACCURATE BASED ON
WHAT WE SEE NOT JUST WHAT
PEOPLE TELL US. THAT IS TAKING
PLACE WE WEREN'T SURE THAT SAN
DIEGO WOULD TURN UP WITH THIS
AND ALSO WE'VE BEEN VERY
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED. THAT
YOU'VE COME THAT YOU HAVE AN
INTEREST IN I KNOW MY COMMUNITY
ALWAYS HAS A INTEREST TO WHAT'S
GOING ON. I APPRECIATE YOUR
ADVOCACY YOUR INTEREST. MOST OF
YOU KNOW WHAT I AM
UNFORTUNATELY SO YOU KNOW HOW
TO GET. AND I KNOW YOU. WILL DO
THAT. BUT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
INPUT OKAY AND SO I'D LIKE FOR
YOU TO. IF YOU HAVE ISSUES MY
STAFF IS HERE MAKE SURE THEY
GET THE INFORMATION IN THE
BACK. TWO OF MY STAFF MEMBERS
ARE HERE. MAKE SURE WE GET THAT
INFORMATION THAT'S IMPORTANT.
AND AS WE HAVE HEARINGS AROUND
THE STATE I'LL LET YOU KNOW
ABOUT THEM. IN CASE YOU WANT TO
COME OR CASE YOU JUST WANT TO
SEND A MESSAGE OR SOMEONE
THAT'S THERE. I WANT TO THANK
THE CONSULTANT FOR US. HE
DOESN'T WANT TO BE SAFE OKAY.
JENNIFER CAM WHO WAS AN AMAZING.
EVERYBODY LOVES JENNIFER THE
STRONG ADVOCATE FROM THE
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO A BRILLIANT
YOUNG WOMAN WHO'S BEEN AT
SETTING WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
HAS BEEN AN INVALUABLE
ASSISTANCE TO ME SO ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR COMING I
APPRECIATE IT SO MUCH AND
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LONG TIME.
TALKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND
THESE ISSUES WE STILL SHOULD
ADDRESS IN THE COMMUNITIES
MAYBE NOT AS A FORMAL HEARING
BUT I'LL TALK TO MY STAFF AND
YOU GUYS THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
JUST A MEETING OF THE COMMUNITY
THE TALK ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
I HAVE A MEETING THE OTHER
NIGHT. TALKING ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES IN PRISONS I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO DO THAT
AGAIN TO ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR COMING AND I KNOW WE. ALL
RIGHT TIME BUT I WOULD I WANT
TO THANK THE LABOR FOR THEIR
SUPPORT